okay
man somebody got really upset about us
saying that like
this somebody put was with putting wally
in there
[Laughter]
i don't remember who it was but one of
the listeners i think i think might have
been victor
said he worked um at uh jag in a box i
think he said 20 years ago
for a while then they put the lettuce
lettuce in after they put the lettuce in
afterwards i saw that i
could be
i was a long time ago back in the 70s
when i had it i left in 81.
i remember other people saying that they
fried the lettuce along with it and
maybe they did it that way back then
before everyone knew any better well
they were just trying to move fast and
you know i mean and i remember the
lettuce was hot could be
that that probably i'm not i'm thinking
about it more from the mind of a cook
because i remember people complaining
about it
i think what was happening is that they
deep fried it put the lettuce in it and
then they to to put those things that
set them underneath the heat lamp
and over time
the oil and the hot lamp [ __ ] kind of
heated that lettuce up to make you think
that they deep-fried the lettuce
and it was probably because they were
pre-making
tacos
you know what i mean pre-making them and
[ __ ] sending them out to the to-go
thing so some of those things might have
been sitting there for [ __ ] a half
hour
getting hot
well that might have been what i was
saying like i said that's kind of my
argument for our always like ordering
something weird at like mcdonald's or
burger king or something because you're
much more likely to get something fresh
yeah if you order something that a lot
of people don't order yeah victor said
that might be why yeah
that makes more sense they were greasy
so the grease would go up into that damn
lettuce and it would wilt a little bit
underneath the [ __ ] sun lamp and it
came in a little paper thing like old
french fries would come in you know a
little paper bag
they were [ __ ] great though and he
says they were two for a dollar they
were [ __ ] good yeah
hell yeah
if you had back in the day it seemed
like if you had a couple dollars you had
a whole [ __ ] feast
well you can do that nowadays because a
lot of fast food places have a dollar
menu yeah it's like that i mean
mcdonald's has a dollar menu bk has a
dollar menu like you're not gonna like
eat super healthy or anything but
you know if you only have like a buck or
two to feed yourself yeah because you're
you know broke ass
you could probably like get your day's
worth of calories now did anybody check
on the on the jack-in-the-box wallaby
scandal
because it's going to be out there
the wallaby scandal it was in the
wallaby or [ __ ] wallaby gate with
uh some people were incensed over it you
know but i remember
my uh my mom's boyfriend at the time
name is dave he was a dab chemical
engineer for conoco oil company
[ __ ] was [ __ ] rolling back in
the [ __ ] strong days of the
california oil industry
and he was like wallabies good quality
meat i need a burger with nothing but
wallaby
so you know not everybody was pissed
about it victor said maybe it was
kangaroo you might see the kangaroo
wallaby well because i kind of feel like
austria
in australia kangaroos are like pests
so
they just shoot them
so maybe that's why the meat was cheap
well they also farmed them they ate
those too that's true okay they eat
those which like i said that only bums
me out because kangaroos are cute but
you know what i mean yeah and we're not
used to eating i remember it being
wallaby and i was because i remember
being like what's a wallaby and this is
it's like a kangaroo but it's smaller
yeah
yeah
but it would i probably mcdonald's was
behind it
how'd you up at mcdonald's i kind of
feel like probably other fast food
chains were probably just like they make
their [ __ ] out of like some growth how
[ __ ] well because when i was a little
kid
my uncle
used to tell me all the time that
wendy's
made their hamburgers out of worms
uh which i remember that spoiler alert
they did not no i remember that same uh
rumor that's because the ground beef
looked like a wavy thing on top of the
patty that's why that's why yeah yeah i
never bought that even when i was a kid
i didn't buy that i'm like even if they
are worms it's [ __ ] delicious so i
don't give a [ __ ] i remember when when
wendy's first came out in the very early
80s out in california
it was a superior [ __ ] hamburger
it was better than the wendy's you have
today much better
much better honestly i i was a fan of
wendy's yeah
i liked wendy's
one of the things one frosty because
hello yeah i also like dipping the fries
in the frosting
also i like that they have baked
potatoes not a lot of fast food chains
have baked potatoes and that is an
oversight i don't think they had that in
the early 80s
because i would always kind of like that
was one of my favorite things about
wendy's is that they had baked potatoes
one of the things i remember about
wendy's though
is that all those little horse girls and
my mom and all the [ __ ] horse girls
and me i was a little kid you know and
they'll call them horse girls they were
all teenagers we would go to wendy's
after they do their little lessons
they'll be wearing their riding britches
and [ __ ]
and that was the first time
i ever saw anybody
get us
get a side of some kind of
dressing i'd never heard of before
called ranch dressing
and they were eating french fries with
right with ranch dressing the first time
i've ever seen it but it might have been
around 79 78
ranch dressing and french fries
you can i mean that became a thing you
couldn't dip french fries in pretty much
yeah that was the thing remember how how
crazy the u.s was about ranch dressings
all throughout the 80s
ranch they they were serving ranch
dressing on everything from [ __ ]
denny's
i kind of feel like the mid-range the
midwest yeah they will put
ranch dressing everything on everything
yeah that's what was happening that's
kind of their thing that was a
california trend
which that came from
in some ways it's kind of gross but in
some ways i kind of get it i get it put
ranch dressing on pizza
okay that's gross yeah sorry
i'm not cooking it cece's pizza had that
damn ranch pizza ranch and bacon pizza
i'm not completely averse to ranch
dressing it's good in some applications
you should never ever ever bake anything
that has mayonnaise in it i [ __ ]
can't stand it mayonnaise is not
supposed to be heat and heated up just
it gets a wang to it this is [ __ ]
disgusting but some people seem to be
immune to that i don't get it
the only time
any mayonnaise ever works out when it's
being baked is in a in a pie crust
a lot of people don't know what i'm
talking about
if you take a bunch of just all-purpose
flour and put mayonnaise in it and knead
it yeah it's like a two ingredient yeah
pie crust that's all you need then you
got your pie crust because it's got eggs
and oil in it so it's got all the [ __ ]
already in it
you say how do i make a crust you got
eggs you have to see if you got
mayonnaise yeah you got flour yep you
got a crust you can make a pie crust
yeah
and people something like what and i
think i'd even talk about that no
cookbook don't i yes there you go
yeah just take a bowl of flour
start adding [ __ ] mayonnaise to it
and stirring it until you have a dough
and take that with your hand press it
down in the bottom of any kind of glass
pan and you'll make a damn pie crust you
can cook it for a few seconds a few
minutes until it's brown and then you
take it back out and put whatever you
wanted it soup or whatever to make a pot
pie or any kind of filling and then put
it in there and bake
and it'll be a light flaky crust like
something of some french [ __ ] chef
made yeah it turned out really nice
beautiful yeah it turns out really nice
yep like i said super easy
um yeah greenspark says underrated
opinion love a baked potato see i kind
of feel like i wish
more fast food places would offer one a
baked potato two
big like chunky fries like wedge fries
or big steak fries
i don't know i kind of feel like
although we've been going like i said
we've been going to bk
more just because it's on the way to the
movie theater it's like the only fast
food place that we can like get food
before the movie theater
and i remember burger king i was never a
big fan of burger king gotta say
um i was always more a wendy's person
yeah and mcdonald's too all right but
what i was gonna say was that burger
king's fries were always really not
back in the day we're not good
because they were always kind of like it
always felt to me back in the old days
the burger king was like well we're
gonna do mcdonald's fries but they
always overcooked them i always kind of
felt like they were too
brown too crunchy it's like they just
didn't do them right
but
now they kind of have like bigger
fluffier softier softer ones and it's
like i don't know they're like way
better all right trey simmons says you
saw that the pliskin shirt comes in long
sleeve are you talking about uh uh the
uh which pliskin shirt the one from the
uh
the factory piston shirt or the ones
that we make i'm not sure exactly which
one yeah if you want one let us know if
you want one let us know but um the the
pla the pliskin shirt that you normally
see me with i have a small one and a
large one
we can order a long sleeve and do that
send me uh probably 25 bucks for that
probably huh
yeah that'll cover like shipping cover
[ __ ] 25 should cover that
drop in a 25 super chat and i'll send it
to you just give me your size
later on and uh send jenny a uh
private message
on what instagram or
youtube probably youtube facebook or
or if you have my email address yeah
we'll get your information facebook will
probably be the quickest get your
information in your size and i'll i'll
shoot one for you
trey says i saw wendy's in toledo ohio
in 2019 that still had the baked potato
bar
man i remember that now victor victor he
worked i missed that he worked at jack
he thought that was a uh
an urban legend that they used kangaroo
meat it's not an urban legend i remember
when that happened it happened in
california back in the 70s
early set and it was wallaby
and they didn't use all wallaby they
used some wallaby they mixed it in with
beef because they got a bunch of it from
australia once and somebody ratted them
out
and i think probably some mcdonald's was
probably behind [ __ ] ratting them out
on that like i said that was probably
like some corporate bitchiness yeah but
uh i wanted to ask somebody to [ __ ]
google that find out exactly what date
that was i believe it was wallaby not
kangaroo tammy said googled it it comes
up as true that jack in the box used
kangaroo meat in the 1880s mid-1980s
okay but like i said i kind of feel like
remember there was kind of like in the
80s and 90s it was kind of like a trend
for hey kangaroo meat yeah they're pests
in australia so it's like really cheap
i remember when i was
younger in the 90s so i was like in my
early 20s
the winn-dixie store a mile for my house
was selling kangaroo meat for a little
while you can get kangaroo jerky and
wallaby yes yes it was a high quality
meat and it wasn't wild i don't think
per se i think what it is is a lot of
farms
had infestations of [ __ ] kangaroo but
they're living there on the farm for a
long time and they go out there and
they've got to shoot all these goddamn
kangaroos what are we going to do with
them you know
the australians are sick of them they
got [ __ ] thousands of pounds of it
they sold it to [ __ ] restaurants yeah
it's good meat there's nothing wrong
with it it's not like i said it's not
like you're eating a armadillo
like i said it means meat yeah it's not
like you're eating
like some gross ass [ __ ] or something
or a [ __ ] an army or like i said a
person you're not eating human meat that
would be much cleaner than [ __ ] a lot
of [ __ ] it probably would um
[Laughter]
but uh it still might be a little
controversial the worst of all of the
[ __ ] vertebrates is a [ __ ]
well the worst of all the vertebrates
would be a buzzard a buzzard or a
[ __ ]
vulture that'd be pretty [ __ ] bad
yeah and then carrying yeah and then
right there alongside that would be a
[ __ ] armadillo
carrying eater and
[ __ ] ass and cajun have been eating
[ __ ] armadillo forever and if they
still doing that the [ __ ] need to be
smacked
there's not that much poverty anymore in
in louisiana you know they do that [ __ ]
really if you ask me a lot of times they
do that [ __ ] to prove
how cajun they are they're stunting yeah
oh we're gonna eat this one
yeah they're like are you gonna eat that
oh yeah you know [ __ ] it dude don't eat
that oh we're gonna eat this one like i
said it's almost like a little bit it's
going into like [ __ ] stunt in
territory yeah just kind of like we're
just gonna eat this gross out of [ __ ]
because like other people don't like it
yeah they do eat roadkill
they do eat real quick yeah my uncle you
seen it all the time as long as it was
fresh
and he would [ __ ] jump out there
if there was a deer that was hit and
he'd run up don't it hey don't waste
that how long has this been here
because this is this is fresh you know i
mean
he'd pull it off the side of the road
[ __ ] get put a pocket knife cut the
guts out of it field dress it and throw
it in the back of a [ __ ] trunk
take it home
and he had a [ __ ] thermometer and
everything to [ __ ] test out
how how warm it was
you know what i mean [ __ ] like uh
this has been out here at high
temperature for too long it's probably
spoiled i mean you have to know you have
to know free food
yes
yeah my uncle was this he was [ __ ]
crazy he was [ __ ] cajun
part of my family though there's a cajun
wing to my family they're [ __ ] crazy
they're funny though they're funny yeah
but you have to think too that's kind of
the same kind of uh logistics that
dumpster divers yeah
would kind of go into where it's like we
jump in we jump in the dumpster and
we're kind of like okay we're getting
free food but is this [ __ ] still in the
package yeah how long has it been in
here has other [ __ ] touched it's not
like that
cajuns aren't like that they're like the
vietnamese of white people they eat
every [ __ ] thing if it's wild they'll
try to well can we do we can eat that
they're like that you know you think we
can eat that uh yeah yeah i think we
need that just
[Laughter]
do they ever consider should we eat that
no
no it's just
and they'll [ __ ]
it just depends on who you're talking
about too they're just like
this is good you know this meat is good
we're not gonna waste this meat although
it's not what it was and then the uncle
that i'm talking about is dead now
he was doing this mostly in the 70s and
the 80s
and uh it was louisiana was more rural
back then
so there was more choice roadkill i
think
[Laughter]
because as it kind of more suburbanized
you didn't see as m as much wildlife
you know i mean yeah across the road so
that i remember that [ __ ] [ __ ]
that's not like back in the old days
when it was like rural and you'd find
like a dead deer oh this just got hit
i'm gonna eat that [ __ ] somebody else
[ __ ] left it and [ __ ]
but um
yeah they should be out of season and
you're worried about [ __ ] game
wardens and [ __ ]
but that was during the time where you
know every [ __ ] house had huge bug
zappers and clouds of [ __ ] insects
[ __ ] being killed by the bug zappers
and
outside every [ __ ]
shopping mall at night ever just [ __ ]
swarms the [ __ ] insects going
underneath those [ __ ] parking lot
lights
and all that shit's gone
i remember that as a kid you were taking
your life into your hands at night
in in the deep south around those
[ __ ] lights nothing but [ __ ]
mosquito hawks mosquitoes [ __ ]
weird cicadas and
moths and [ __ ] just swarms of them
i guess
insecticides got them
yeah
those big old [ __ ] black locusts
yeah i saw them a lot as a kid yeah gone
like i said my grandmother probably
killed like a large portion of the
population of those sphinx moth larvae
eating it eating things up it's all just
kind of [ __ ] it's gone it it's all
gentrified now
they gentrified the
it used wilderness
be like the amazon basin it did yeah
yeah
trey says red robin has the steak fries
yeah they do
we've had a red robin a couple times but
that's like a sit-down restaurant that's
like not fast food that's more like fast
casual i guess that's more like a
sit-down restaurant and they have the uh
unlimited french fries you can get all
the french fries you want he's talking
about the zazzle store
yeah okay yeah you can do this as a
store although
i'm not i had one of those shirts and
that that [ __ ] that's done by a robot
that actually sprays that on there and
it didn't last long at all [ __ ]
although to be honest with you i have a
bunch of those zazzle shirts and they
still look good they look good my flesh
can shirt disintegrated after about a
year maybe it's maybe your like sweat ph
is not conducive to you you just have to
say okay maybe you're just dirty
no
no i've had a lot of those and it's like
they're still they still look good tammy
says not eating human meat yet
yeah so i agree
i'm not a verse depends on depends on
the situation depends on who we're
talking about
who are we talking about eating
i'll eat some [ __ ]
so like green all depends on how bad
[ __ ] goes i mean you could google this
[ __ ] just look up [ __ ] shine it was a
chinese flesh banquets
back back during the 70s and 80s
during china's cultural revolution
he had chinese people eating other
people in a thing called a flesh banquet
because they were capitalists and it
wasn't because of starvation they did
survivors of it people that were around
said no they weren't starving it was
just revolutionary hatred
they would [ __ ] get into a damn
circular firing squad and just start
accusing somebody of being a a
capitalist and the next thing you know
they're saying all the capitalists are
trying to eat us and eat our profits
trying to eat us with profits and [ __ ]
and they jump on some [ __ ] beat
him to death and eat them
well sounds like a myth but it's true
it's and there's whole books of it
chinese flesh banquets this shows you
how evil people can be human beings are
evil hairless monkeys never forget that
you whip them up into a frenzy they'll
do anything it's always witch trial [ __ ]
dancing diseases back in the middle ages
just
well weird [ __ ] behavior from crowds
not everybody does that though it's
masses it's crowds not everybody does
that though there's always a certain
percentage that are like yeah no i'm not
doing that yeah but i'm not worried
about them i'm worried about the
percentage that does it you know don't
don't try to be a savings
no i'm just saying do it i'm just saying
not everybody's dangerous
yeah they are
i'm just saying that
yeah like i would eat people if i had to
you know
everybody would but yeah it's if it came
down to like well we're going to die or
we have to like eat a human yeah yeah
obviously well there's people that's
playing crash victims and [ __ ] you know
hunting somebody down and eating them
yeah i wouldn't do that now if somebody
really really sucked
um and like they were the worst of the
worst
uh and they
did something to me that was like really
super bad and everything like that and i
really wanted to punish them i'd you
know i'd probably eat them so you're
going to go hand up a lecture on them
sure okay i'm not saying that wouldn't
happen i'm just saying okay because that
would be like i know they're not going
to be like alive to enjoy it
but i would get some satisfaction out of
it i had to be in a really bad mood
well obviously yeah but you know i don't
know i kind of feel like i'm always in a
bad mood
[Laughter]
so i so i could kind of i could kind of
see myself doing that but you'd have to
do something really
really bad robert's back after the
buffering yeah really we restarted
yeah we had a restart because my [ __ ]
went like [ __ ] red light karen says
back in the 60s we had a bug fogger that
would drive around i remember those
things too the biggest yeah yeah yeah we
had that bug trucks yeah we had the
mosquito trucks and like had all the and
it would like smell really weird yeah
they would fog up your whole downtown
people would [ __ ] a brick if they saw
that [ __ ] today back when i was kid we'd
be out there and the [ __ ] truck could
be going
blasting that fog out of the back of it
we'd be dancing in it
dancing in that [ __ ] well that
explains a lot thomas did you sleep
oh they were saying it was [ __ ] safe
for humans it probably ddt
oh i'm sure it was but we were [ __ ]
dancing and having fun well even back
then nowadays like you know it's kind of
like my parents were like yeah don't go
outside when that's like [ __ ] spring
we don't we don't know what the [ __ ]
in that [ __ ] i don't know what was in it
it's probably nothing good
but i do remember that um
it's the mosquito trucks yeah mosquito
trucks yeah
and they would go down the street and
stuff yeah i'm sure it was probably ddt
before that was illegal yeah ddt
probably i heard that the ddt um thing
was kind of a
a corporate
power struggle that it was nowhere near
as dangerous as that they were saying
that there was no that uh they did some
that a lot of tests against it were
fraudulent
that ddt was actually a miracle uh
insecticide that
saved millions and millions of people in
africa from uh what do you call that
[ __ ]
not bubonic plague what do you call this
[ __ ] [ __ ] not influenza
you get it from mosquitoes
clogs up your [ __ ] encephalitis or
malaria malaria okay malaria did that
save millions of people in africa from
malaria and that yeah some that that
some people could have had reactions to
it but it was kind of the thing where it
was such a slim possibility it was and
it saved so many people when it was
around
i remember that they said that they
thought that it might have been a damn
conspiracy to get it out of the hands of
the africans to help to prevent
overpopulation in africa
but that might be plausible
although everything's not a conspiracy
it's not a conspiracy i mean it's never
a conspiracy when you plan to drop a
bomb on a [ __ ] when you plant
the kills it's just you know what let's
not give this these people because they
might overpopulate that wouldn't be a
conspiracy
that would just be a direct action
um
there there are corporations that do
that kind of [ __ ]
but uh
yeah that might have been dvdt
but there i remember [ __ ] seeing
films on training films from like the
[ __ ] 50s and 40s about ddt or might
have been 50s
where uh they would just spray spraying
kids with it and then like all their
headlights would fall off like they go
up to appalachian [ __ ] spray the kids
and the whole house the [ __ ] ddt to
[ __ ]
get rid of lice and head mites and
[ __ ] all kinds of it probably worked
probably worked real well
do they still do that [ __ ] nowadays
because i kind of feel like when i was
in elementary school in the 80s and you
know my parents were in a daycare as
well
yeah every now and then you'd have the
people come in and check everybody for
lace yeah
i think that's what i did i think it's
all been wiped out
i mean i would hope so but i remember my
dad took the dog and put the dog inside
laid a blanket down on the ground
in the [ __ ] living room
and put the dog in the middle of the
blanket and wrapped a dog up in a
blanket and then took a [ __ ] spray
can
a [ __ ] ddt
and sprayed it in there on that dog and
kept the dog fighting for a few seconds
and and they let the dog out and in the
center of that [ __ ]
um uh blanket it was a pile of dead
[ __ ] fleas it killed every flea on
that dog
that's how good that [ __ ] was
how long did that dog live not forever
well not it died
you know
years and years
but uh yeah it was a trip
i remember it
i remember my dad talking [ __ ] about it
too this is gonna get him that was what
it said on the instructions this is
gonna get him
there was an outside dog yeah
backyard out in california you're this
is going to get them
this will kill everyone in the fleas
watch this you know
and hear the dog in there barking i'm
fogging the dog bugging it dog dog
[ __ ] yeah and he let the dog out and
his dog was like what the [ __ ]
what are you doing a big old pile of
dead fleas that's killed every [ __ ]
fleet just fell off that dog and they
were and they weren't even moving
from what i remember
the fleas weren't even moving killed
them instantly
some [ __ ] man i don't even know they'd
sell anything like that nowadays
probably not no because i'm sure there's
all kind of like horrible carcinogens
and [ __ ] like that in that dog didn't
seem to mind
well how would you know it's a dog
[Laughter]
they don't they can't really like talk
to you and be like hey can you like not
do that got rid of please
you can drop it in the comment section
if you guys remember that
yeah yeah that i kind of feel like that
should be the brand name this is going
to get it yeah yeah tm
yeah yeah victor said we had those
mosquito foggers up in the 90s here in
texas i kind of feel like we had them
until
kind of it was the early 90s right it
was probably the early 90s because i
remember them going down the street like
but when i was at my grandmother's house
and that was like earlier see trey
remembers that [ __ ] says yeah the south
and the 70s bug wise was [ __ ] scary
it was a neon
remember those [ __ ] swarms and then
all night long you hear bugs hitting
those [ __ ] lights
and then they are so big that it was
yeah yeah they'd hit it
and then sometimes the bug would fall
and hit the asphalt
and then go
and then take off again it was [ __ ]
bizarre it's like straight out of
something out of [ __ ] stephen king
movie like the mist well i told you yeah
that's a [ __ ] like that my grandmother
yeah back in the day
she was kind of she was a tiny tiny
little woman she was probably like my
height five foot two five for three
maybe ninety pounds this tiny little
woman
but
she was
um
bad ass
she did not
brook
any snakes any insects anything like
that in her little garden
she had she grew tomatoes [ __ ] like that
she would go out there every single
morning
and any
snake that was out there any insect that
was out there she was just like taking
care of it and she would like not even
like she would pick the [ __ ] up with her
hand those big grasshoppers yeah those
big ones
she would take it and she'd be like
yeah and she like throw it into the road
and she did the same with snakes pick
them up y'all probably remember those
[ __ ] black grasshoppers oh you know
what happened with me like one time this
is like really upsetting well
once an animal this is weird but like
once an animal gets to a certain size
squishing it is not not enough on the
table anymore um i'm not squishing a
mouse okay that's bigger than crawfish
once they got blood yeah so once you get
like to the size of like florida
grasshoppers yeah
that is
that's not acceptable but one time i was
taking a walk around my grandmother's
neighborhood
and i wasn't really looking where i was
going and apparently according to the
person that i was walking with
i stepped on one of those without
looking at it and that still haunts me
to this day yeah because i didn't know
because those [ __ ] were
big big
yeah like that and they were like super
super meaty first time i saw one i was
probably about five mississippi and ran
up on one that was out in the dab front
yard of like a great aunt's house she'd
been long dead she was anxious back when
i was a little baby
i ran up on that black grasshopper and
that black grasshopper looked at me and
those wings
started fluttering with those yellow and
purple they scared the [ __ ] out of me
man yeah they're like red yellow black
yeah my dad started pulling me back
don't touch it that's that's a locust
and i just remember oh it scared the
[ __ ] out of me last time i saw one was
um
around 2000
maybe 14 when we first started hanging
out
yeah i was working at the barn that was
a long time ago when was that 2011
actually i wasn't 12.
i used to be the caretaker
for the uh for a real
uh
rich
doctor okay his family built orlando
general hospital his name was dr matt
his mom built that hospital
and dr matt
had a big old southern style plantation
mansion and a barn
with about six horses in it
so i took care of his barn and all of
his horses and [ __ ] took care of his
grounds he'd go out he he and his whole
family would
go to egypt and [ __ ] israel he was a
jewish doctor good guy
and he could they go to israel for
[ __ ] months at a time and i'd take
care of his grounds for him that was
like
he was bad ass man he had a big property
i went there a couple of times like when
you were working there he's big into
like ar-15s and [ __ ] he was a little
cut
he was he was a science guy a little
weedy
kind of nerdy guy but he really liked
military stuff so he would talk about
his ar-15s and guns and [ __ ] he he liked
to defend his house you know so he
trusted me with his
his his grounds and his horses and stuff
last time i saw one of those black
locusts was in his barn and it was
on its side fighting with itself dying
remember how they would just kind of
like start dying and malfunction like
they're so big yeah that [ __ ] was huge
and that's a bug but it's like massive
when was that
2015.
i met you
in 2010.
so it must have been around 2011.
during the time you used to come to the
barn and [ __ ] watch me work yeah i
used to come with you a lot yeah a lot
yeah i only had to work
twice a day
go down there [ __ ] take all the
horses out muck stalls
do basic grooming on horses
yeah we took all the horses out to like
the pasture and have you go like clean
the stuff yeah and then like a certain
and then
um on certain days i'd [ __ ] mow the
place you had those big right on mowers
and [ __ ] make sure your feet let all
the chickens out feed
chickens um did a little security he had
a large property or it was near our old
house before we moved here
because it's a real nice neighborhood
you would never know that was there it
was like something at disneyland
white well it's like on this little
bitty street that's like a little bit
private road yeah and uh
like seriously maybe a mile or two from
our old house yeah and um
it was uh
it was pretty neat i'd love to have a
house like that but that was [ __ ] 5
million at least and that was five
florida million which that's the [ __ ]
lie yeah that was a massive that house
was [ __ ] beautiful and it wasn't one
of these
mcmansions that was real wood and real
old school type [ __ ] but it was it was
modern
and he had a lot of property a lot of
property yeah that wasn't big it wasn't
an old house but it was built like an
old house very it was very expensive
it
he could pull his house he could pull
his car in and it had like an over it
had a
big rotation a big uh rotary driveway
that went in front of the house and you
could pull up into a carport that had
overhang and you get into the side and
then the car could go into a [ __ ] a
remote garage
it was nice there was two stories and
grand pianos and you know this is
[ __ ] nice he had uh a pool and a
jacuzzi didn't he
yeah pool and a jacuzzi and then a bunch
of property and he had corn out there
and [ __ ] a little farm
it was funny because he didn't need it
it's just it's what they did
so
he just kind of like he liked to pretend
that he was living in the country he
wasn't in the country
not really
no he was in especially not nowadays no
because we live in that same
neighborhood we used to live in that
same neighborhood like it's all
suburbanized it was basically the um
orlando's version of beverly hills but
it was he had so much property it felt
like you're in the country big old
[ __ ] trees and [ __ ] horses
but that's the last time i saw one of
those black
black locusts
and you see it starts off as a
grasshopper but something happens to its
stress it can't get enough
they start out as like maybe if you if
you're watching the [ __ ] instead of like
listen to it they start they start about
this big and they're black with like
yellow stripes on them yeah
but
then for what some years it i don't
think it happens every year
but
whatever like if the environmental
situation is right or something like
that they kind of like
hulk out
and they become these big huge
they're like how long are they they're
like at least
they're like six inches long seven
inches long they become these big huge
yellow and black
striped
massive thing well and they have their
armor
yeah and they have big heads and they
have like these wings that have like
black and red
they're massive
yeah and
it like i said it doesn't happen every
year it's like a locust kind of
situation but
i remember them a lot from when i was
growing up because my grandmother
she was kind of
my grandmother was kind of sheila just
joined i know i just saw that yeah my
grandmother was like in a constant fight
against them because she was always
trying to grow tomato plants
in front of her house and those locusts
love to eat tomato plants
so she would have to go out every
morning like on reconnaissance
and like pull them off of her tomato
plants because they were eating all the
leaves and she'd pull them and she'd
squish them and she'd throw them into
the road
and it was just kind of but they were so
big it's like they were as big as
[ __ ] mice
yeah you know what i mean so it was like
i don't know what like i said once an
animal gets to a certain size whether
it's a bug or not it's always like
really upsetting to like squish it
because it's like it's
it's like a real animal at that point
you know what i'm saying
it's like one thing to like squat swata
fly or something like that which is like
tiny but bigger than a crawfish yeah
they're big they're big they're big kind
of like you're in the presence of a very
small lobster
yeah
yeah that's cut yeah they do fly yeah
um they're not gross though they're
actually kind of cool looking mean
they're mean though they're they're well
they're aggressive yeah they are
aggressive
victor says i just watched eight-legged
freaks last night it's on netflix
robotic i uh i actually really like it
late eight-legged freaks um big-ass
spider is another one that's uh decent
in that same
genre
if you're into that
uh yeah hi there
mr roboto man everybody's like showing
up late yeah friday night it's all right
we're still working
tila says i looked in the fridge no
juice got to go grocery shopping vodka
rocks for me tonight yeah we got to make
a supply run i got to go to uh sam's
here too man i got all kinds of frozen
stuff
but it's kind of like just nothing but
pork tenderloin i need some variety i
got a damn
beef roast in there i made some beef
sandwiches the other day i [ __ ]
roasted that [ __ ] [ __ ] out on the
[ __ ] grill used that liquid smoke on
it made good beef sandwiches roast beef
sandwiches we've been eating like roast
beef sandwiches for like three days yeah
off and on and pizza and i'm not
bothered oh yeah
well
after the wednesday night show after the
wednesday night show
um tom's like yeah i'm going to domino's
because that's
like i'm like so drunk i barely remember
yeah at least well i at least i ordered
it right online because i was scared
yeah i was kind of like
and i was like trying i was like oh my
god
hopefully this i don't like give them
100 or something but i did okay
um you got me i don't remember what you
got but you got like some pizza and i
was just kind of like well just get me
like a medium pizza because i can't eat
that and i sat here and ate every single
piece
of that pizza because you know drunk
when you're drunk everything seems like
a good idea
and
i to be honest i'm actually glad that it
didn't like have any adverse side
effects because usually
if i eat that much pizza at once the
next day i will be like oh man like i
will be barfing my [ __ ] face off yeah
but next day i was like oh you know what
i i feel okay hugo says i've been
looking big i'm hitting the gym and
probably lots of juice no
uh normal 200 uh milligrams
of test a week do hcg
and a couple days ago i got some juice
you know you don't see any juice effects
right now
takes a while for juice effects comes in
but uh it's part of my trt protocol i
have a
a synthetic testosterone like substance
let's just put it that way i'm going
through it puberty part three right now
[ __ ] sweating out that grease
smelling like a damn evil gorilla again
my mind's good though my mind's alright
um seems like all you've been doing is
sleeping though sleeping sleeping and
hanging out at the biker bar yeah it
makes you real sleepy well it's only
been two days makes you sleepy i did a
[ __ ] i lifted today and i [ __ ] hit
the [ __ ] out of that [ __ ]
i was just like man i was a lot stronger
and now and then as soon as i got done
it told me to go to sleep it was like
the poultry guys jumping on me said you
better [ __ ] sleep
but i had to do the show i was sitting
there fighting it
fighting it felt like i was on morphine
or something
but then i made a comeback i fought my
way back through that cloud that cloud
of masculinity i had to come back out
and make my comeback do the show we're
all very proud of you yes had to take a
shower and everything just get that
[ __ ] smell off me like somebody
[ __ ] slapped me up with crisco
that's right it's like it's like it's
like zach's did something bad to me
i don't know the i don't know this
cracks me up because i'm just kind of
like um
i don't know i don't talk about you i'm
talking about
well i'm just like [ __ ] i'm tired all
the time like 24 7 and i always have to
be like man i have to like do this that
and the other thing
so i always kind of have to like
bring myself out to do it and it's kind
of like so she's been getting a lot of
[ __ ] a lot of orders a lot of jobs
her cut her clients are [ __ ]
constantly got her out there working
doing it and i got two jobs i got to do
in the morning tomorrow on saturday and
i thought i was gonna have a good day
i know it's good
but
i kind of feel like people do kind of
pile on at the end of the week they're
like hey can you do this like yeah
well it's so funny how it just evolved
to where you're not you're just working
for yourself now
yeah which like is that money you lost
working for those others i wouldn't go
back yeah but it's a it's still
stressful it's just a different kind of
stress
and honestly it's like it's stress that
i put on myself i guess largely and i
think a lot of the problem comes from
i'm one of those kind of people that
like if somebody gives me something to
do like for example like somebody sends
me like a client something hey can you
like do this poster or whatever
um
i don't want to like think about it for
longer than i have to
so i will do it as quickly as i can
manage
i want to get
i want to get it out of the way you know
what i'm saying
there you go sexy hat i'm putting
can i put the sexy handle let me see the
section let me see what it looks like on
me i don't think i've tried something
going back to sexy cowboy hat sexual
tyrannosaur here you go
wait probably look better on you than it
does on me well everything does oh
oh oh oh he got yeah put that on there
you go
yeah yeah yeah
it does it does it looks good you can
wear it you can have it
all right you can see it it's hot that's
the only thing i don't like about it
well it doesn't breathe right it's kind
of hot i'm used to that yeah
[Laughter]
actually i want one that's a little bit
smaller
it looks right it is kind of big because
i'm waking up i have a big head no you
have hair yeah i'm bald so it's it's
loose
i like it actually here
i kind of feel like
face me i gotta get i gotta it has to be
rakish
very rakish like this
there you go there you go i feel like i
should be in the jenna torture yeah
that's what it is i'm gonna whip some
[ __ ] yeah torture his hat yeah
i'm elsa she wolf of the years
you guys know about that yeah but yeah
so um so what was i saying so
i kind of so i like to get stuff out of
the way
so
consequently
many of my clients because i have like a
handful of regular clients that i do
[ __ ] for all the time
and so they have gotten very used to me
doing their [ __ ] like immediately
so there's kind of a thing where
you know it's friday
afternoon like 4 p.m and i'm just kind
of like whoo end of the week we're gonna
do the show now i'm gonna drink we're
gonna relax and then suddenly i get
three emails from people that are like
hey can you do this [ __ ] for me like
right now and i'm just like no i cannot
but i'll have to do it like this weekend
even though i don't want to so
there's that whole thing
that's that that's the only thing about
like i said i wouldn't go back to like
doing nine to five [ __ ] because that
blow that blows
but
doing [ __ ] freelance
you
can't really have a thing where it's
like oh it's the weekend now because
a lot of times people will send me stuff
and i have to do it like i have to work
over the weekend
i don't really get a day off
in that sense because there might be
easy stuff coming in both of you all
could take my money thank you very much
thank you
that that was sexy that would be yeah
that is sexy on you jenny that would be
even sexier if your boobs were out
we got to get you something low-cut i'm
not going to get like why are you trying
to get me demonetized not too much no no
not not totally out i'm just saying we
need some like you know
oh sorry [ __ ] from jenna tortures so i
have to wear something
with some cleavage yeah i have something
i have stuff like that it's just like i
don't usually wear it on the show
because on the show i'm trying to like
just relax everybody is too distracting
huh
well yeah look at it look at look at
look that looks good
what oh you missed it here
i missed what
it looks
see it looks good
what i'm super happy
like i said i'm into it
you guys saw the jen and torturers back
in the day
we saw them not too long ago we went
into gym
we did
that was a while back that was probably
[ __ ] man how many years ago was that i
don't know
i saw her a bunch back in the [ __ ]
90s but we saw her in 2014
2015
something like that yeah if you guys
don't know who we're talking about i'm
gonna show you
guys gender tortures [ __ ] come on
i like this hat
yeah it's good it is big
i see what you're saying
it's big
but i don't know i i always kind of like
thought of myself as a hat person i like
hats yeah
i like
hats i like i like a lot of action going
on up here
on the top of my head
it distracts away from my actual face
there's jen from jenna torture yeah yeah
yeah that was a good album i got that
when i was in the i have that too yeah i
have the cd actually yeah it's good it's
right back there somewhere kind of uh i
saw her on that tour yeah honestly we
saw her a couple years ago and she
doesn't actually look that different no
she looks just like that she looks
pretty but she talked to her
[Laughter]
she's up there trying to sell merch she
was selling merch people were buying
from her yeah saw it um
firestone
that's right
yeah we saw them did we see them by
themselves or were they opening first
that might be is that fire still right
there or is that or is that uh is that
the castle
ooh
uh
i don't think that's the castle
but yeah that wasn't that long that was
around that temperature yeah
trey says uh
oscar says jenny i mean if you got it
flaunt it
trey says i've tried hats like that too
and like tom said they just look too big
on me and i have hair it's just they
never sit right
yeah it's just kind of like that's a
medium i need to get a small
and you know because i'm because i don't
have any hair so it just honestly i
haven't loose i have kind of a very
small head
and
i have hair but not that much hair
because the sides are all shaved i only
have hair on the top
but i kind of i always feel like i look
better
with stuff up here see this is the [ __ ]
man look i got i got kanavatsaland who's
a regular he's he's in tijuana send me
pictures of what he's eating live live
on videos now look man are we gonna are
you eating gorgeous yeah i'm gonna be
hungry yeah i'm eating gordita we're
gonna have to like make food after that
we didn't go down to mexican restaurant
and go buy some gorgitas it should be
closed though it's too late it's too
late to go to internet that's exactly
what
pretty much what they look like here
well that's that looks exactly what like
what you make yeah
similar
he makes his own
tortillas and everything
yeah i'm kind of like
i'm looking at myself in the thing going
like i don't know i
i don't know i don't know how i feel
about this hat it looks good
i don't know you just need the rest of
the outfit you got the rest of the
outfit you just got to put the rest of
the outfit i do but i'm not wearing it
right now like no
goddamn that would look good you wear
that to club
you're going to like bequeath this to me
then you can have it yeah no i don't do
that i'll get another one it looks nice
on you though i'll get another one i
want to i want a smaller one
that's a medium one are you saying my
head's too big you have hair
how many times do i [ __ ] say that
you have hair you have hair so yeah it
it it's about right because i'm bald
it's got to actually be smaller than
that
yeah yeah like i said i feel because
there's slack in it i feel like ilsa she
loses yeah
i need like a [ __ ] whip and
yeah thigh-high boots and
yeah you have we gotta get another pair
of demonia pleasers
i have some knee-high boots i don't have
anything but it's my thighs are too big
for thigh-high boots
i can't wear that [ __ ] what are you
doing pope
what
hey what have you decided what have you
decided
come here
everything's gonna work out on you
though
you'll be able to wear all kinds of [ __ ]
it's going to take time
you got you on a good program
good program good diet your exercise is
right your hormones are right
just wait
you
you [ __ ] have
re uh you you've uh
there's been recomposition happening in
you big time
your legs look totally different
well yeah and i have actually like
slimmed down in my midsection yeah
telling you that was that was age
yeah and it's kind of like you know i've
got my exercise bike and i'm doing like
that every day
that's helping well not eating as much
helps as much now that helps a lot too
now you can metabolize build muscle and
burn fat and you see you have to have
the right hormonal
[ __ ] levels going on in your blood
chemistry for that to happen you have to
basically be in a perpetual teenager
blood chemistry
ask bee's nest he's not in there right
now i got that [ __ ] on the same program
a male version that program has lost 80
pounds in about three months
because you can burn fat
and because you can now eat and you and
when you work
your body responds
it's hormonal
as soon as you get past 40
the hormones aren't there so you got to
put them in there it's called hormone
replacement although like i said i kind
of feel like the older i get the better
i feel
eating
less
if i eat too much at one time
i just always feel like i'm gonna throw
up yeah
i can't eat a lot of food at once
oh my goodness look at her look at her
what you doing huh
what's up poop elsa sent her a little
well it's not little it's big
it's alm it's like half her size and
it's like a little dracula yeah and he's
crinkly
and right now elsa is at the club with
uh
with dj with dj maniac there and she is
like super into that like dracula right
now what are you doing stop tearing [ __ ]
up hey no
no she knows exactly what i'm talking
about tearing up the posters
well because we're not paying attention
to her so she's kind of like i'm gonna
make all this noise give me the crinkly
ball poop okay
yes
don't talk back
talk back to your mama don't touch my
butt
yeah karen says tom your arms are proof
to me thank you very much karen
i could have done this at
16 17 18 25
past 30 35 it would have been hard to
maintain
after 40 very difficult after 50 no
[ __ ] way
you have to go through hormone
replacement therapy which is legal and
cheap and supervised by doctors and
regular blood work
and yeah to get started
you're probably going to lay out about
600 bucks to get started after that
you're probably looking at about 200
bucks a month
but you get your needles your hcg to
keep your [ __ ] fertile
it's a
it's a [ __ ] fertility drug and then
your testosterone supply once you got
that and your blood chemistry starts
working out with your [ __ ] quarterly
blood tests
you see what's going on
you work out
and the body responds now it's like you
were you when when you were a kid if you
lose your eyesight you wear [ __ ]
glasses if you lose your teeth you put
in false teeth
if you lose your [ __ ] hormones you
put in hormones it's just that's in you
your metabolism will run right
and you'll live longer jack elaine lived
into his 90s doing basically what i'm
doing now just that they he probably
didn't use tests he probably used a
mixer test and anavar
and as long as you're not abusing
anabolic compounds in your youth and
tearing yourself up for that first 40 or
50 years as long as you're not doing
that you're free to kinda use whatever
agents you want in your second half of
life and it will be
the science and the data proves that if
done correctly it constitutes life
extension
you'll
function as a younger person if you
catch it early
and you'll live longer
you'll avoid osteoporosis you'll avoid
clogged arteries you'll avoid uh things
that are associated with obesity
uh
it'll keep
stage two diabetes from becoming stage
one and you can actually reverse
diabetes that's been reported also i had
a propensity towards stage two
but once the once the weight loss is
there and ever it
has been mitigated and blood pressure
goes down
and uh then that propensity towards
stage
type two diabetes starts to go away i
don't have any diabetes my [ __ ] blood
comes back clean as a [ __ ]
i have the red blood cell count of
[ __ ] of like an olympic athlete
my doctor said next time you come in
here for a test go ahead and give blood
i guess because the red blood cell cell
count this high by law it's like not
really supposed to be treating you
you're too healthy
[Laughter]
they know what they're doing you know
but uh
yeah
i don't get winded i could run forever
because it's got so many red blood cells
oscar says how bad is alcohol for muscle
growth
uh depends
if you are depending on
natural testosterone production
it's bad because alcohol is a
suppresses your natural testosterone
production so that could affect it but
you see i don't worry about natural pre
testosterone production because i inject
it
so i have testosterone no matter what i
do
even if i miss sleep it doesn't [ __ ]
matter
i have testo okay here's the deal on h
without testosterone replacement therapy
i was making 146 nanograms per deciliter
normal is more like 600
so i had the testosterone levels of a
[ __ ] very old man
uh that could happen for many reasons
depression anxiety
ptsd is another thing that can do that
uh when i went on hc hcg my testosterone
levels went up to 900 nanograms per
deciliter that's [ __ ] very very good
all right if i come off of hcg it stays
around 850 900 that's my normal
production
when i'm injecting like what they give
me i'm somewhere between 1600 and 1900
that's [ __ ] super human
that's just
top of the line grade a male at about 20
genetically gifted is about 1200 i'm 16
to 18. so
if i was a girl with implants i'd be
like [ __ ]
if i was a girl with boobs i basically
would be [ __ ]
penelope black diamond that chick with
the [ __ ] beach balls that's that's
what my testosterone level is now
there's other things you can get your
hands on
okay
um anabolic agents that if used properly
you can come down on the testosterone a
bit or you can keep it the same
and you could use those agents and those
agents actually reduce androgen loading
so in other words it's not as much
stress on you as normal testosterone but
the anabolic growth agents
are like six to one versus the other
stuff so you can put on a couple pounds
the key to all that [ __ ] is not to
overdo it minimum effective doses
do not become addicted to it don't go
out there and try to put on [ __ ] 60
70 pounds of muscle the heart is not
meant to drive that much muscle
that's the problem with a lot of those
ifbb [ __ ] bodybuilders on the [ __ ]
on the olympia stage those dudes are way
way way above genetic potential
and muscle is very
hungry for blood
and those their blood pressures are
[ __ ] super high and they get tired
really quickly
you don't want to really go above the
genetic your genetic potential which is
really
on me that's another 10 pounds probably
maybe 15.
that would be my that would be as big as
i would get under perfect natural
conditions you go above that
you're constantly going to have to be on
some kind of drug to maintain that
muscle mass
and why would you want to do that you
want to get to about what your potential
is and then just nurture that for the
right and be healthy for the rest of
your life you're not trying to be
like that [ __ ] conan in that painting
i had back there you don't need that's
not what you're trying to be just trying
to look good and be healthy that's what
that's all about
looking good being healthy living a long
time
okay i'm done
all right
tila says jack lalanne went to my high
school berkeley high famous alumni
he was a good dude and one of the first
really [ __ ] professional dudes when
it came to
health and fitness
and he was about my size i think he was
five six
[ __ ] swam across the english
channel [ __ ] carrying a
[ __ ] robot in his teeth
can she get out yeah okay
come here
rubber kitchen says i have a really bad
habit of eating before i go to bed i
don't usually do that um
[Music]
sometimes if we drink a lot like if we
come home from the bar and i'm like
really hungry like i'll eat right before
i go to sleep but i don't usually
like right now i'm really hungry but i
haven't eaten all that much today yeah i
had eggs like early this morning
and then i had like a yeah sandwich like
at like two or three in the afternoon
but i haven't eaten anything since then
so
i don't know like i said a lot of times
that's kind of the thing you drink a lot
drinking makes you hungry
so you have like a lot of you know you
drink a lot and that's a lot of calories
and then you're kind of like man i want
some pancakes or
some [ __ ] you always want like some
carby food or like some eggs or
something
or some fatty
you know
i don't know like
but to be honest with you yesterday
i ate
almost nothing
i ate one tiny roast beef sandwich
and two cups of coffee that was all i
ate all day yesterday because like i
said you came home from the bar and you
fell asleep
and
so you didn't make anything and i was
just kind of like well i'm not gonna
make anything
and then by the time i got hungry i was
like well it's too late for me to go get
anything so i was like well [ __ ] it i'm
just not gonna eat
victor says i need to look into trt
[ __ ] did he what he says i lost uh
10 pounds after switching jobs that's it
i'd like to lose another 30.
[ __ ]
we've had a guest on the show named the
angry gay pope angry k pope's been on
[ __ ] trt and [ __ ] anabolics for
[ __ ] ever but they gave him that
because
he has another illness that he's
constantly fighting
but uh the um
trt [ __ ] out in california [ __ ]
you can't go into a gay club if you're
not [ __ ] on trt
that's like trying to be a porn star
without [ __ ] breast implants
but angry gay poke [ __ ]
he extols it he keeps asking me tom are
you on trt i don't [ __ ] answer that
[ __ ] let's let him wonder tom
you on testosterone
he asked me that [ __ ] in public
a private message so i just don't answer
that [ __ ]
he's cool though yeah he's cool but he's
had he's that he's asking me that [ __ ]
in public
on facebook
well there is
a private question i mean you know
on the show i'm a [ __ ] open with it
you know what i mean but you know just
i do joke around in in public on [ __ ]
facebook to my friends they know what
i'm talking about because everybody
knows me knows what i do
and uh
but i just got this [ __ ]
angry gay pope
jumping up out of the [ __ ] coming out
of the california closet he hadn't been
in the closet forever but he's [ __ ]
jumping out tomorrow you want to you're
on trt if you're if you were gay you'd
be on trt [ __ ] like that you know not
answering that [ __ ]
i don't know why that's the line that
you draw on the sand
because i'm i mean you know we're kind
of like pretty
although you know what i get it like
we're on this show
um you know you guys come and watch us
if you guys know us like we'll pretty
much talk about any whatever on here i'm
like i'm not real worried about it i
can't you know what now that i'm
thinking about it i can't think of a
single thing
well i'm sure i'm probably good i can't
think of a single thing that like if
somebody said something about it i'd be
embarrassed about yeah can you think of
anything no i'm not embarrassed i just
get [ __ ] annoyed about it imagine if
you had some chick just keep asking if
you had implants
yes yeah the implants jenny do you have
implants yes i do have implants do you
have implants
but [ __ ] ask me five times i've
already answered him in public so i just
stopped answering it yes it's like he
doesn't [ __ ] have doesn't look at the
mat it doesn't look at the look at my
responses
i have implants because when i was
younger i used to be really really heavy
i used to be like 250 pounds or
something like that you carried it well
though and then i lost a lot of weight
and my boobs deflated yeah and so i got
implants yeah
uh so because they were big before that
yeah so
so when i got the implants it honestly
was like can you just fill these back up
please because now they just look like
kind of like another good deflated like
pancakes yeah because i used to be like
kind of fat so that's why you carried
the weight pretty i'm still kind of fat
but i'm just saying that i use as much
as you i used to be like much much much
better yeah
when she lost all that weight she was
unrecognizable i was one of the few
people at the club that knew who she was
yeah yeah everybody else thought that
was a totally different woman everybody
thought it was a different person yeah
ah yeah that's funny yeah i lost like i
never know that she lost all that weight
though she like 100 pounds it was 90
something pounds yeah 100 pounds
something like that skin looked good and
everything you'd never know that she
lost that much weight
yeah
and you know how i did this just i i
just stopped eating for like five months
not not completely not a good idea but
that's what she did yeah but well i was
kind of sick of it yeah i was just kind
of like you know what i'm just gonna do
like a short term i was like i need to
get rid of all this [ __ ] yeah so i said
i didn't like stop eating completely but
i was like i'm going like super low
calorie and i got an exercise bike and i
just did like miles and miles miles like
every day
and i said i'm still gonna eat but i'm
just gonna eat like no carbs no fat no
nothing and so like no sugar no nothing
is this it which one is it this one
that's water okay
um
and it works like five months i lost
like almost 100 pounds
um
it wasn't completely without uh side
effects because i did have i developed a
heart palpitation
and i had to go to a cardiologist and
they had to put like a [ __ ] heart
monitor on me because i started getting
like i said my heart would
uh would speed up it'd be like and then
like i started like passing out
so i had to go to like a cardiologist
and they're like well you're probably
fine but you know you lost
so much weight in such a short amount of
time that your heart doesn't know what
to do now
uh so
you know you have to like wait and like
regulate it so i had to like kind of
pass out
for a while and kind of get used to it
it's fine now i still get that every now
and then but it's not as bad as it used
to be because i just gained some of it
back because like i said me and tom
moved in together and he's like hey you
have to eat all this fatty food so you
know i gained probably like 10 or 20
pounds back
but
i mean you know i i don't know it was
just kind of like it was probably stupid
but
i was
almost 40
um i was getting divorced from my first
husband and i was just kind of like look
i'm sick of being
heavy and i was just kind of like i just
really need to
get rid of all this [ __ ] like right now
i wanted to like [ __ ] purge
everything so
i just went on a kind of like
i just went on a really really low
calorie high exercise low calorie diet
for like five months and lost a lot of
weight
and at which point
like i said i started going out again
and everybody started noticing because
they're like who's this girl
i don't think if people remembered me
from like back in the old days because i
was like
well i one i was like super heavy and i
was like really shy so i knew some
people from back in the day but it
wasn't like the same
you know the people who didn't really
know who you were before had no idea who
you were no they didn't yeah
so to them it kind of seemed like when
me and you started hanging out together
it seemed like she was i came out of
nowhere but i've been hanging out there
for like years and years but nobody
noticed me because i was chubby yeah i
said and i'd be like they were like
who's that you see you don't remember
her and she's like no dude you know who
that is dude you know and i just kind of
laugh i didn't really say anything so
she's come here all the time you just
don't recognize her she was married at
the time yeah
and [ __ ] then i would describe who it
was i said remember the big old tall
girl a big old tall dude and the [ __ ]
and the girl little short stuff like the
big tall red headed yeah you know and
[ __ ] they're like that's her you're
like yeah that's her
they're like because i looked totally
different yeah
thank you tila yeah here's to good
health to tom jenny and all my friends
in the chat seriously yeah
but um
yeah she's kind of down on herself you
know what i mean she she she's
got getting back into shape um she's
probably lost about 10 pounds in the
past month couple months maybe
yeah probably but the thing is is that
you don't need to lose weight you need
to recomposition you really only
you don't really only need to lose i'm
going to give the guys in the audience a
mental image
if you lost about 10 pounds of fat and
gained 10 pounds of muscle you would
look about like sophie d if you guys
know sophie d's you can google that
that's about how her build is with the
implants and shits i do have a she has a
function i have a similar build to her
yeah she she's
has a good build when she's in form
she's just a little bit but hey it's
been 10 years you're pushing 50.
uh it's not really normal for a woman to
be able to support
um proportions like that at 50 not
without external support
you have to have like i said in a lot of
ways it's harder because women gain fat
and lose muscle mass after and if you're
short if you're short you're very
sensitive like i am you can't really get
away i'm seriously five foot two five
foot three on a good day and um
unforgiving proportions really yeah same
with me at my side yeah so you you know
so in a way and like i said my whole
maternal side of my family
um on my mom's and my aunt my mom and my
aunts and stuff they're all built like
me they're cut they're real short real
short waisted
uh big thighs
really short calves really short legs
um you can't really gain a lot of weight
or you'll look like a big chubbo
so
i you there's not a lot of like wiggle
room yeah and sadly and unfortunately
for jenny she inherited kind of like
some kind of a genetic disposition
there's two different kinds of women
some women as they gain weight they put
it on in the ass and the thighs not me
jenny gains it right in the midsection
yep which that's there and a doctor
mentioned that and he [ __ ] somebody
i was listening to his show and somebody
in
interrupted him in the middle of his
explanation he goes well you have to
understand when you're dealing with with
hormone replacement or two kind of women
some women running and gaining it around
the uh uh the the ass and the and the
thighs but other women gained it around
the waist and with those you have to but
then then they interrupted his ass i was
like what the [ __ ] man what was he going
to say
because he was an ex well i kind of
gained it i don't know i i feel like i
gain it in my thighs
more than my ass my thighs and my
midsection
yeah not so much the ass though i wish
all the i wish all of the weight would
go to my ass but it doesn't here's the
thing it goes like to the outside or the
inside of my thighs and my stomach
here's the thing i got i got tila in
here she's going to represent the
[ __ ] african booty queens of the
world
[ __ ] a
real booty is has a very
um solid muscular uh support system
underneath it you have to gain weight
in muscle not fat to get
good booty okay the only way to do that
was two you can do
um leg extensions and leg curls and you
can do squats there's a couple of other
little but the thing is is that the way
you are where your blood chemistry is
right now
that would be highly effective
um
three sets of 15 not even that much
weight less than 100 pounds probably in
a period of a few months give you
[ __ ] good results but you have to
listen to me it's not aerobics aerobics
don't do that resistance training does
that weight training does that
it doesn't have to be that much weight
not in this not in the
not with your blood chemistry the body
will respond
just
i'm a physical trainer not only of
soldiers
in the field i'm also a physical trainer
horses i i can do that too i know how
that [ __ ] works
just you know they got people that oscar
says how do you lose face weight
um okay well it depends on how old you
are uh as how old you are what your body
chemistry is if anybody like knows let
me know uh well it's a couple different
things that you can chew gum like crazy
that's one thing i did that yeah i did
that for a long time another one thing
that you can do is this
do this and that'll tighten that you
know what's better nothing is you can
weight your head do your uh do fish lips
there's a bunch of different things that
you can do now if you want to use
[ __ ] anabolics
uh if you start going on anabolic cycles
and start [ __ ] getting down to the 15
body fat
a lot of
probably a lot of that will come from
your fate come out of your face
and uh if you look at
[ __ ] guys that are [ __ ] with
anabolics they'll fall into two
categories a meat head which is just a
[ __ ] muscle just like a [ __ ] meat
head that's one thing and sometimes i
have that meat head look
or they just [ __ ] death head just a
skull
they get so lean they just look like a
goddamn skull
and uh you never look like a skull the
thing is is that it's it's reversible
either way it's not permanent it depends
on what your blood chemistry has been
doing the past couple months
because you can lose or gain weight
rapidly or and sometimes it's water
weight it's a lot of that meat head look
you'll see these dudes look like
something out of [ __ ] gears of war
these damn video games
a lot of that is kind of water weight
from [ __ ] around with [ __ ]
anabolics like like d ball like dana
ball do it prima bolden can do it um
it's kind of reversible but a lot of
these guys you talk about that are
[ __ ] huge are on that [ __ ] 24 hours a
day seven days a week their entire lives
they're just [ __ ]
[ __ ] themselves up with lots of
anabolics at once
it's kind of like manorexia it's a
little bit like drug addiction for some
of these guys
so i'm saying this is [ __ ] is you have
to
have the right kind of mindset and be
the right kind of person you got to be
very disciplined to do pro athletes pro
soldiers special forces guys delta force
they're [ __ ] with this
mercenaries some of the best mercenaries
in the world are on all this [ __ ] a
normal man can't live the lifestyles
that they live
beyond the age of [ __ ] 35. they've
got they they have external support
they have [ __ ]
[ __ ] tons of [ __ ]
just like a pro athlete they have a lot
of medical
assistants
they know exactly what they're doing too
i mean
navy seals
they were doing weird things with their
blood because those early re-breathers
because that [ __ ] puts all kinds of
toxins in your blood so we're taking a
lot of drugs to help them
deal with swimming with rebreathers
which is like a breathing apparatus
that converts carbon dioxide back into
oxygen it doesn't make any bubbles that
way they can swim underneath the water
without making real low signature no
bubbles
so and it was just like this burning box
of chemicals that they were breathing
out of
real bad for you
it's a lot of [ __ ] that [ __ ] elite
soldiers were doing a lot of people
don't know about they were given a
methamphetamine they give [ __ ] jet
pilots some of those
a-grade top gun pilots they're on meth
keep them from sleeping
well i kind of feel like even back in
the old days because if you watch like
movies or
uh military recruiting videos from back
in the old days
they did not make a secret about it no
have some bennies yeah and also super
soldier serum [ __ ] like
all right steroids gotta be yeah
all right i'll go ahead and address it
look like tilas i see tila's name coming
up let me put my glasses so i can see
what she's reading
to talk and talk and talk
oh she's talking to other people
karen rob says this so tom gets it i'm
not really sure what you're talking
about karen
nice tom gets it
oh here we go [ __ ] [ __ ] tila's
laughing at me
squats and donkey kicks yeah squat
challenges i do them all the time tila
suck yeah i know tina talk to this girl
you got her with the fake fingernails
she's wearing a fake fingernail you got
a bunch of wigs you need to [ __ ]
educate this white girl on booty okay
bad girls are the [ __ ] sorceresses of
booties i [ __ ] you think we don't
know we know
booty sorceress
yeah
looking for the if taylor says she's
looking for the booty emoji
she goes yeah keep cocoa butter and shea
butter on that booty stress point yeah
you know what's funny is that for the
week that she lost she doesn't have any
stretch marks
she's got real good high quality
skin and good
good um
see i look at a [ __ ] like
they're a horse or a cow i know what i
mean this is biology to me
she even really recovered from surgeries
no scar tissue she's got [ __ ] which
is uh you know for a lot of people with
fair skin they scar easily and you see
this car it's not her
you could cut her open and [ __ ]
there's no scars afterwards she's got
real good recruit recuperative abilities
and her skin can stretch out and then go
right back no stretch marks
literally look which is good shape she
looks just like sophie d
google that [ __ ]
that's what she looked like [ __ ] six
years
ago listen to the [ __ ] team but she's
talking to you right there jenny
but uh i was just saying how good your
recuperative abilities are no stretch
marks no scars
oh my you you're genetically gifted
about that but you don't really realize
it
um
amount of weight usually people have
[ __ ] stretch marks i do have stretch
marks no but
nothing compared to what it
very mild very very mild yeah a normal
person would have been like that's not
even something you could still like as
you look like sophie d when you're in
form
she has similar kind of little stretch
marks here and there that's just kind of
normal for women because their weight
fluctuates that's all it is and honestly
to be honest um you know like you lost a
hundred you don't look like you lost no
well that looks like you lost about 20
pounds or 30 pounds that's because i
started putting like cocoa butter on the
[ __ ] like immediately go ahead and read
what tv was telling you on the stomach
on the thing and like i said i've never
been you know i've never been like
hugely pregnant i've never been like i
was overweight i had like really bad
stretch marks like on my thighs mostly
they weren't dead um
well for a time
yeah maybe they went away you had some
for a little while but then they did
they're they're actually gone now but
like i said that's because i kept
putting cocoa butter but for a time they
were bad enough i was
uh self-conscious enough about them that
do you remember we went to
susan yeah and i was going to have
tattoos
yeah over them
because i really didn't
yeah and that was after i lost weight
because i was like look i lost all this
weight and this [ __ ] is still here and
it like looks really bad and then two
years later all that [ __ ] started to
fade yeah well you know like i said it's
that's what i was going back to
something i said like probably like two
hours ago you guys are seeing that girls
every single tiny little thing
which maybe other people don't notice i
don't know but we notice it and it's
just kind of like we make a huge deal
about it yeah so
every single imperfection
we're gonna obsess yeah about that [ __ ]
that's just that's what we do and it's
just kind of like
because someone's gonna notice it
somewhere
and someone's gonna point it out to you
and then you're gonna get like [ __ ]
uh you know you're gonna get all [ __ ]
insecure about it
yeah so for a long time i had stretch
marks because i was much heavier and so
i was like maybe i can get tattoos out
and cover it up and i was gonna cover up
the tattoos we went to a tattoo artist
that we know yeah me and you went it
would have been a mistake actually
well i don't know about that because i
like tattoos and um
and i honestly would like to get more i
just haven't been able to afford it
honestly i want a big [ __ ] back piece
i wish somebody would do that i want a
back piece
that's based on
have i said this before i want a huge
back piece that's based on
uh
mask of the red death yeah i have an
idea for it
yeah i want the whole like the grim
reaper thing and the like all the colors
and the clock and all that
i want to [ __ ] i want that all over
my back
but i can't afford it so i haven't got i
haven't got it done yet but that's what
i want
also i want
this i want this tattoo
expanded into like a whole egyptian i
want a whole sleeve
but like i said i can't afford it so i
haven't done it yet
but you know and they're saying oscar
says jenny does have pretty great skin
no offense tom yeah that's one of the
that's one that i said i actually do
have i do have nice skin yeah
i gotta
i don't because the lighting on the show
i always kind of have this [ __ ] meat
head look on my face a lot of it's the
lighting and [ __ ]
sometimes it's the [ __ ] that i'm on at
the time
but uh
my body fat percentage right now is
probably about
17 18
probably about 18 but when i get down to
15
you'll see some changes there and uh
maybe depending on how things go there's
a possibility i can be in the sub 15 but
that might take six to eight months
we'll see we'll see how we'll see how it
goes
um
like i said
when you start dipping into sub 15
[ __ ] fat
there's no way that can be done
after 50
with a normal biology you have to have
external support then you need the
hormonal support to get that done
you'll never be able to burn that fat
go ahead and read some of the comments
but no what i was gonna say was that um
one thing like i said
i have a lot of things i don't like
about myself well one of the things that
i do like about myself i did inherit
some really nice skin even when i was a
teenager
i never had acne
i always had beautiful
clear
i was like fat but i had beautiful clear
skin uh so i didn't have like i didn't
have acne and have all that kind of
problem i always had beautiful skin so
that was one thing that i uh inherited
from my mom so thanks mom
um you know so
see she said you also had great skin
which you do
victor says i heard models use
hemorrhoid cream to shrink pores
i had heard that also i don't know if
they do that anymore but yeah that just
smells so bad i don't think they'd do
that anymore does it smell bad nowadays
though yeah i think it usually has kind
of a [ __ ] minty smell to that
[ __ ] well that was an old trick
that's all like preparation h kind of
[ __ ] but that's kind of like
i kind of feel like people still have
this perception nowadays like something
like um
what's that [ __ ] that they used to like
take your hair off
nair yeah yeah
back in the old days i never used nair
because it smelled like
rotten eggs yeah
but i got it a couple years ago
and i was like oh it doesn't smell like
anything anymore because nobody's gonna
buy it if it smells like [ __ ] rotten
eggs so you know
robert says i'm 37 and still get acne
what the [ __ ] it just don't go away yeah
so that's the thing
listen to what [ __ ] t says about
booty
says about booty what where what she
said a whole [ __ ] dissertation about
booty
booty dissertation uh they're up here
the dead africa
just about squats well everybody yeah
everybody knows about squats yeah squats
okay i do i just go out you say anybody
can get a nice booty with squats yeah i
do squats
i do squats too i do squats bike with
high resistance yeah that's good the
bike with a high resistance is good
because you get a mixture of stuff yeah
i got a whole
basically professional [ __ ] gym in in
the room next door
and uh man during the pandemic people
[ __ ] kill to get in there
you know it's all gold gym equipment and
stuff
and um
women
because of their culture
i think they like aerobics
is not very effective i mean
bodybuilders [ __ ] looked into
aerobics they try to see what they could
gain and what the results of aerobics
are you can gain endurance you can get
rid of some fat
the problem is that if you look at very
attractive women what is making them
attraction attractive is not the loss of
fat what is making them attractive is
their [ __ ] body composition they have
a lot of muscle on them
and if you go on instagram there's a lot
of different kinds of girls that are
getting involved and [ __ ] they do not
look like the bodybuilders of the 70s or
80s those girls [ __ ] were basically
failed experiments really they looked
[ __ ] terrible some of them they're
too god damn lean
it's a mixture of fat and muscle to get
that [ __ ]
voluptuous look
um
some of them are using body filler you
know tila tell you about that you know a
lot of those [ __ ] girls that are in
the [ __ ] rap scene they're using body
filler but that's okay that's the look
that they want um but it also involves
resistance training their [ __ ]
weights
and weights is so much easier i hate
aerobics they used to make us run 10 15
miles of [ __ ] day in the army
it just
it gets to a certain point you just
don't gain anything from it and
i like to what
changes the body's shape
is basically
weight resistance because it's just so
concentrated you've put out so much work
in such a short period of time the body
is so damaged it now has to [ __ ]
lay down there and repair and that
repair causes the new shape to form and
it grows
but you got to have the body chemistry
for it after 35
the results aren't there
there's not enough time left in your
life span to get any results because
your endocrine system is
with each year declining so yeah it's
going to take 10 years at this rate but
the problem is 10 years from now you'll
be 45 and then the rate has even falled
off even more you must have external
hormonal support which jenny has that
which
and everybody above
everybody who's pushing 40 needs to be
on hormonal support if you want to live
a long time or if you want to look a
certain way
don't believe in that richard simmons
[ __ ] man richard simmons never got
[ __ ] built okay he wasn't on anything
you gotta get on some [ __ ]
well
i don't know if that was necessarily the
audience that he was he was kind of more
targeting just like regular ass people
yeah but there was no results
but like i said he was kind of like just
more encouraging people that didn't like
to exercise he got fat
that he was just kind of like well do
something that's better than nothing
you know what i'm saying which it is
you're programmed to die
well done everybody is after a certain
amount of time
the hormones just aren't there so you're
going into death mode you get
everything's shutting down
the metabolism is starting to collapse
because
you're in the past now you're beyond
[ __ ] as far as nature is concerned
you're in the past now yeah there you go
there's he's coming for you right he's
coming for you so you have to
artificially you have to artificially
induce a young metabolism it's just done
through exogenous [ __ ] testosterone
and hormones and anabolics and that'll
[ __ ] bring it right so the last half
of your life you look [ __ ] look at
lauren lopez google lauren lopez
bodybuilder the girl's like 52. she's
like a [ __ ] 10 out of 10.
all right but she's been on that [ __ ]
for about 10 years she looks good
i just like i said i kind of have like a
funny or i don't know i have like a dark
comedy like yeah look on it i'm just
like yeah everyone's gonna die
but you might as well you might as well
die in good health you'll live longer
yeah i'm all into that but
you know
and you'll have a better quality of life
[Music]
richard simmond
yeah
every time people would [ __ ] with
ridiculous about him being fat
because
he wasn't listening well he wasn't fat
back in the day he was just like he
wasn't ripped or anything he was just
like regular but like i said i think
that's what helped him to appeal to
because like i said his whole appeal
was to
regular people that didn't
normally like work out
he was kind of like appealing to people
that didn't normally do that type of
[ __ ]
that was his audience
so he knew how to react to it there's
lauren she's about 52.
all right that's not natural
if you think a 50 year old 52 year old
woman could look like that naturally
you're [ __ ] tripping
okay here from florida that's anavar
anavar and probably testosterone
there's another picture of her
and when you see videos of her she's on
youtube we're just walking around
you would think that was a 30 year old
woman
listen to your uncle tom he's telling
you some good [ __ ]
tila says the best richard simmons
impersonation was done by eddie murphy
and then yeah professor yeah you know
what i don't think i saw that movie
that i'm thinking about it it wasn't one
of his best movies but it was a funny it
was kind of funny that was during
eddie's [ __ ]
i don't want to say decline it was just
that he was well i'm going to dress up
like everything kind of yeah he was
going amazing i'm going to play all the
parts in the movie yeah he was kind of
going i'm going to be a big fat white
woman yeah
he was going mainstream and kind of
g-rated or pg rated
has have any of y'all seen the haunted
mansion movie because it's like i kind
of want to watch it yeah it was never
but i kind of don't
because like i said
you guys know we you guys saw the dark
disney show i love the haunted mansion i
love the whole like
mystique about the haunted mansion i
have books about the haunted mansion
i'm not really sure how i feel about a
movie made about the honda mansion
especially with eddie murphy i love
eddie murphy don't get me wrong but
he has a certain
uh thing about him that i don't
associate with the honda mansion you
know what i'm saying
you know not hating not hating but it's
just kind of like
so i don't know if i want to watch it or
not con goes man that was santa muerte
yeah senator martha yeah yeah it's all
that drug dealer [ __ ] going on like i
said
we got the skulls too death is coming
for you [ __ ] yeah yeah
bee's nest sent that to us
um and by the way by the way khan i
showed him your gorgitas
i got the same goddamn corgitas over
here near my house i'm [ __ ] i was
getting hungry man i was thinking about
going down there and getting some well
it's closed now
now you got to make stuff no it's close
i got tacos can we order dominoes it's
too late
it's not it's only 9 22. they're still
open uh they close at 10.
man you're trying to get me fat every
time i go to donald's uh domino's i'll
get a whole [ __ ] pizza that's gotta
be 1700 calories
and i'll eat that old [ __ ] too
wait wednesday what's that after the
show we ordered dominoes well you went
down and got it they didn't bring it
and i ate
it wasn't a large pizza i ate a whole
medium pizza
yeah but to be on to be fair
the whole entire next day
i ate
i hurt i didn't eat hardly anything i
ate one sandwich like the next day and
that's it
so
i don't feel too bad about eating
homemade and also i rode 10 miles on my
bike so
i'm going to see i'm going to see if i
have any corn tortillas left if not i
have to make some of them a sec it takes
too long
because i got i got carnitas though i
got carnitas i also have
i also have [ __ ] fish sticks frozen
fish sticks to make a good fish taco but
i don't have yeah like eat fish taco i
got oh i got oh another half and half
two i have two frozen hamburger patties
and two hamburger buns
okay i can do that
well how fast will that be not long okay
easy
tila says funny movie jenny check it out
when you get it okay yeah
right now on um
like i said i should have saw that movie
well
i have like a i have a thing about like
the honda mansion
because
disney world
i'm really into like the disney world
haunted mansion yeah and i like the
whole mythology about it and the fact
that they made a movie about it and it
was like comedy and i was just kind of
like i don't know how i feel about this
you know what i mean so i was just
kidding was it as good as vampire in
brooklyn
i like vampire in brooklyn and honestly
a lot of people [ __ ] on a vampire and
blitz brooklyn but that was actually a
good movie yeah that was actually it had
a lot of shout outs to [ __ ] uh
blacula and screamed back at the screen
it kind of went along that way okay i
liked it okay um
there's rumors tila i don't know if
you've heard this but there's rumors
that eddie's gonna do another [ __ ]
axel foley movie another beverly hills
cop
i mean it would kind of be dumb not to
because everybody's doing like the 80s
it's about time yeah and i loved one and
two three was mediocre it wasn't that
good uh it just had a weird cheap feel
to it the edit was wrong it needed to be
edited down into something you could
tell they were just kind of pulling that
one out of their ass
it didn't have a good script
but um
i still watched it though
you know it was okay
but it it needs you can't let axel
foley's story end that way
on that
note
from three
they need to come in there with a four
and don't call it axo-fold e4 or
anything like that you got to call it
something totally new but everybody
knows what it is
what the [ __ ] has axel foley been doing
he couldn't be a cop anymore
it's been too long
i mean do you really have to i cut yeah
i kind of feel like you'd really need to
like feel the weight of what had been
going on this whole entire time what
happened something bad must have
happened to him he's got to be coming
coming out of retirement for something
you'd have to have a [ __ ] i mean
that's a pretty common trope but yeah
you could do you could do that you could
work with it be the same way you know
rambo coming out of retirement you know
something some for some reason [ __ ]
axel's got to be going on an
investigation and he's not a cop
see
maybe he could be like a private
detective he could be a fish out of
water no it's just him
pretending to be a private detective or
something like that
and i just see him
lars ulrich says is that a dark
reference
can i just ask you uh the golden child
was his best by far i loved it i was
good honestly i got it i like the movie
yeah
um
i i i i want the knight
yeah um honestly i loved the [ __ ] out of
that movie yeah uh
okay they played it on cable all the
time i probably saw it like at least 50
times
we saw it again recently i don't like it
as much as i did back in the 80s
but it's still really good i loved it
back then what a weird premise i loved
it back then i see it now and i realized
that it was a very low budget
independent film that delivered it gave
you [ __ ] eddie murphy in a fantasy
almost indiana jones type setting well
that's what they were that's what it was
supposed to be and it did work
it was not as high budget of course as
indie but sure it was [ __ ] fun to
watch
i have it on dvd i don't have it on
blu-ray and i think a blu-ray release if
i don't know if it's out there but a
blu-ray version would be even better
i liked it
and um
the special effects probably would don't
really hold up probably especially i
mean they're good for the day though
they're good they're good for the time
um
i'd like to see what the blu-ray
treatment would be like on that
because it would probably show a lot of
weaknesses in that but you know what
that's not what that movie's about that
movie's about story
story and it's a good-hearted movie
good-hearted adventure in a way it's
almost kind of like a team's down
version of eddie murphy doing big
trouble in little china kind of felt
like that yeah to me it's more like big
trouble in little china yet it is
indiana jones yeah
and not [ __ ] on big trouble in
little china because i love that yeah
that movie's bonkers though that movie
is blockers so what's wrong with that no
nothing i'm just saying it's kind of a
toned down version of big trouble in
little china yeah i mean big trouble in
little china like i said if you're going
to be like [ __ ] bonkers just like
lean into the bonkers yeah which that
movie did and
more power to it that's why everybody
remembers it just him mentioning that
movie makes me want to see it again we
have big trouble in little china i think
i bought you that you got it the steel
book special steel booking i bought you
this book
box got a truck on it
if you guys noticed something funny
about that is that crustal
crustal when he's doing um escape from
new york he's basically doing a clint
eastwood impersonation
yes when he's doing [ __ ] big trouble
in little china he's doing john wayne
yes
that's exactly to do it
and i didn't notice that at the time but
i see it now and that's that's exactly
what he's doing he's a big silly john
wayne hero that never he he's not really
doing any of the work the chinese guys
are doing everything
which is kind of the
it's kind of poking fun at the old white
savior trope where the white guy shows
up
to solve all the problems that the
chinese had because there was a lot of
that [ __ ] going on yeah but that's he's
not solving any problems he's [ __ ]
failing
but you have to read in between the
lines and i was waiting hold on the
chinese dudes did that not him yeah yeah
yes but
it is funny
i guess you couldn't be as overt with it
back then yeah he had to be slightly
under the table i think because i mean
now it's like pretty nice it's like
watching it but yeah well you know to
get to get people to come see the movie
the box office you had to have [ __ ]
kurt russell as the leading man and he
had to be the hero
so you had but really the movie just
pretends that he's the hero
i think his sidekick does most does gets
most pretty much
and then the chinese dudes do most of
the fighting he shoots the [ __ ] tech
night in the air and a [ __ ]
brick hits him in the head and knocks
him out and then they all fight each
other and he wakes up it's over
remember that yeah
and then he doesn't he he doesn't really
do much with the magic i gotta see that
[ __ ] again
yeah
see how i correct my memory
of that
in my memory he really didn't do that
much he was just there
pretending to that he was okay and then
that's it you know what i mean wait hold
on did you do anything
i didn't really see you doing that
i'm just gonna like take all the credit
yeah you know what i mean yeah that's i
think that's how i remember it it may
not be true though we'll see trey says
escape from new york is one of my
all-time favorite movies mine too
t says kurt russell in the thing was
fine as hell in that movie i just
watched i just watched reactions to that
movie like five of them yesterday and
the day before
of of young people millennials and [ __ ]
watching that movie couples and girls
and [ __ ]
and that movie still stands up this
movie still holds up i have it
i love that movie and it's funny that
young people
don't know the movie when they see it
they're like man that was a really good
movie
uh because the story's there
the story's there
it doesn't do any of the [ __ ] that a
lot of hollywood movies do
especially today like today they would
never allow that movie to be filmed
because there's no women in it but
that's what part of the thing that makes
that movie so [ __ ] weird it's taking
place in the 80s there wouldn't be any
women up in antarctica
that would just be
ex-military guys on these little [ __ ]
outposts be boring as [ __ ]
um it would be a sausage fest it'd be
just like an oil rig out there in those
oil rigs there's no women out there
well the fact that there were no women
there made it like
that was another feeling it was like
adding to
their isolation and that was another
thing the element of realism it's just
dudes and they're all a threat to each
other
and they don't trust each other
and uh it kind of works out maybe and
then the end is ambiguous what happened
the way i took it
cart
killed
childs that's how it i think happened
you know why i think that
the scene where kurt
is playing the [ __ ] computer chess he
can't win he loses so he pours the dirt
is the [ __ ] whiskey and goes cheating
[ __ ] yep and walks off fries the
computer 80s style [ __ ] that computer
that's some 80s [ __ ] there right even
though he just broke me and hold on
broke a whole [ __ ] chest king
compared i'm sure other people had to
use that kurt right
so then
childs comes in after the big all the
fight and it's cold and it's burning
and [ __ ] crustles says well you know
i don't think we're in much [ __ ]
shape to do anything about it you know i
read about each other and says maybe
we'll just wait here we're just going to
stare at each other see what happens and
he goes yeah
and then [ __ ] crustle hands him the
[ __ ] whiskey and he drinks the
whiskey and that's it
well was that the same as pouring the
whiskey down into the [ __ ] see i
honestly i kind of felt that yeah that
was like uh i thought that was a
reference right like he can't win so
cheating [ __ ] i could be wrong but i
thought that was a rough concern i kind
of think i kind of think
the child's was the thing
or i yeah i kind of feel like because
there's
a content child was a thing yeah and if
he wasn't the thing
crusoe knew it wouldn't matter they were
both dead anyway
so he might as well toast the dude even
if he is
a human
remember when [ __ ]
when child's
is [ __ ] guarding the door
and uh nals is down on his knees going
you know i had to cut him loose you know
[ __ ] because because i found this you
know
and [ __ ] windows goes
it goes let him in
but what if we're wrong and child goes
well then we're wrong
that's the same [ __ ]
thing that crustle is thinking at the
end if i'm wrong well then i'm wrong it
don't matter yeah it doesn't matter
because we're all dead anyway
so the safe thing to do would be to burn
childs up yeah
because it wouldn't matter they were
both going to freeze and he says you
can't allow this thing to freeze they'll
just the when this when the rescue team
comes they'll just wake it up
so i think you burn childs
god damn every that movie is so [ __ ]
well written man god it's [ __ ]
brilliant yeah and it's like it's sad
because i kind of feel like when it came
out
the world was not ready yeah it happens
all the time we were already out of the
sky chariots of the gods we weren't
ready yeah and so it came out no one was
ready
but
many years later
at least we can appreciate it because
god damn that movie was like [ __ ]
brilliant and like i said people
watching it nowadays
kids watching it nowadays being like oh
my god that's like [ __ ] yeah it's
brilliant yeah it's brilliant yeah yeah
[ __ ] tina's talking about keith david
[ __ ] how how awesome he was as a
child he's good at everything i love him
that dude impressed the [ __ ] out of me i
was a kid my dad took me to see that
thing like three times down in
mississippi and [ __ ] the
kurt russell and keith david's [ __ ]
they just stuck with me the rest of my
[ __ ] life those two characters childs
and [ __ ] mccready
because they were just two examples of
[ __ ] how to survive
you know and i just
they were the stars of that show
definitely yep
and um
remember i saw like a uh a [ __ ]
documentary on um
uh african americans in horror
and they had some actors talking about
it you know foreign
and one of the actors says yeah the
thing is is that uh our characters you
know they always die and [ __ ] keith
david is not mine mine lived right to
the very end
and they were oh yeah that's right well
that movie was a [ __ ] masterpiece
yeah
that's and the acting was [ __ ] great
in it the acting the writing the
storytelling and when that movie got its
ass beat by e.t
john carpenter was never the same
and it's never the same that's what i
mean that kind of bums me out because
that sucked everything out sean
carpenter
um
was an amazing filmmaker and i kind of
feel like man halloween was like a big
success then he makes the thing
which was like his vision man he's like
i'm gonna make like you know
the thing from another world that was
like his favorite movie when he was
growing up i'm gonna remake it but i'm
gonna do a different like uh
interpretation
so he does that
and then
nobody goes to see it pretty much
i mean
and so that kind of soured him on
hollywood like forever you got bad
reviews they're like oh this [ __ ] which
is like stupid but it's it's kind of
like a masterpiece look man the shining
got bad reviews in 1980.
just goes to show they know what the
[ __ ] they're talking about like i said i
you know i'm not [ __ ] on film
critics like across the board
you know a lot of them have gone to film
school they do understand the kind of
[ __ ] whatever it's like you know
i do kind of like respect their opinion
to a degree
but
they don't have a real good track record
actually you know i think one they don't
have a real good track record of like
saying like because you could like
[ __ ] there's a whole thing where you
could go back in time and be like this
movie that nowadays 20 years 30 years 40
years later you could say is like a
brilliant masterpiece and critics at the
time just like [ __ ] savaged it i
think i remember remember siskel and
eber the fat one was ebert right
or was that cisco
no the fat one was ebert ebert okay yeah
right i remember roger ebert
and if i remember correctly he was
talking [ __ ] about this movie this movie
is disgusting and i remember cisco going
like what what what oh wait that might
have been opposite was the other way
around
i think it was i think the skinny guy
was going we're talking about that was a
[ __ ] great movie i have to look back
i can't remember one of them was looking
at the other one like he was [ __ ]
crazy like no that was that was a
masterpiece
the story was there the realism it felt
like they were really out there and they
were out there in the snow and the thing
about it is that i kind of feel like
nowadays it's better um like i said i'm
not go i'm not romanticizing the past
because
back in the past in case you guys don't
remember
uh critics did not like horror movies so
if it was a horror movie
they were just gonna [ __ ] on it no
matter
what happened no matter how much
artistic um [ __ ]
[ __ ] it had to it so
i kind of feel like but i do kind of
feel like as much as [ __ ] on like robert
roger ebert
he did actually seem to most of the time
he did actually seem to recognize
even if something was a horror movie
he would recognize something great in it
which you know like i said i that's cool
because
for a long time
being a horror fan
particularly in the 70s and 80s
honestly a horror movie would come out
and everybody just like uh automatically
you'd [ __ ] on it if you're a critic yeah
hugo's talking about the prequel she
said he's requesting a review on it
we'll review the prequel um i actually
really really liked it we saw in the
theater
once or twice twice
um and
i i honestly really liked it i liked it
there was uh
there was i i i overall i enjoyed it i
thought it was a worthy success i did as
well you did
as well um one problem though
originally it was designed for
a john carpenter homage
practical effects
and evidently the practical effects
looked [ __ ] great
that's what i heard but the studio said
no we want it to be more we say we want
cgi it's a cgi over the [ __ ]
practical effects
which evidently [ __ ] up you see me
sighing yeah
and evidently that really [ __ ] up the
tone of that movie
because uh people that evidently had
seen
the practical effects and how that was
going to look they said oh man that
looks just like
the carpenter you know what i mean like
an upgraded version of an homage to the
carpenter with all the practical effects
and i really would hope that they would
re-release a version with the practical
effects at least some of the practical
effects showing
what i really liked about is that they
in in the end they went down into the
damn saucer and showed the [ __ ]
saucer from the inside because as a kid
i always want to know what it looked
like in there
yeah they showed that they showed that
and the weird ass to split 3d
dimensional displays
now
i like the fact that they mostly kept it
as a sausage fest they had one woman in
there which that was realistic because
they brought her
from the mainland to investigate this
[ __ ] she wasn't working there in the in
the 80s it would have been all men
probably still would be today i don't
think there's any women
out on oil rigs if there are there
wouldn't be any american or european
women maybe some
chicks from [ __ ] philippines or
thailand or something
um
but i don't think there'd be any western
women out there
um
but now it
it was good
real good i actually really haven't i've
watched it like i said we we saw it
twice in the theater yeah yeah twice
yeah i think we saw it twice in the
field we'll do a review of it we'll
we'll review it i kind of feel like we
talked about it yeah we mentioned it i
think we talked about it at some point
um tila says
you're so right jenny even to this day
horror is so undermined and there's a
legacy of great movie making horror
i do kind of feel like it's better
nowadays um much better
but
i remember when i was growing up
if you made a horror movie
and you made something like the thing or
the shining or something like that which
is
i'm not even like great horror movie
that's just like a great movie
full stop
you make something like that but because
it's a horror movie
it's already kind of like
knocked down to like a lower level yeah
t oh well we're not going to talk about
that in the same like serious situation
that because it's a horror movie so it's
like a lesser genre yeah that was that
generation fortunately is gone now
thankfully they're gone they passed
along they had a bad they didn't like
horror or sci-fi they didn't respect the
genre but t um i don't know if you heard
that our other review or the show go
check out last night in soho you'll
[ __ ] love it it's good
man i loved that one it was a good movie
it was so good i just kind of want to
see that again that was so good yeah
real good
but yeah it's okay same thing for you uh
khan go see last night get last night in
soho it's good it's real good great
music too good story i really like that
movie a lot paranormal thriller slash
[ __ ] and i ain't gonna spoil it just
there's a lot of it's not the kind of
movie you think it is
it's good well if you see the trailer
yeah and i think i mentioned this on the
review because i kind of feel like oh
the trailer spoiled the whole move the
whole movie it doesn't no didn't even
scratch service nope there's a whole
bunch of other [ __ ] going on there yeah
but yeah i do kind of feel like
it's better nowadays like i said because
back in the old days i kind of feel like
horror was always kind of like dinner oh
it's like this bee
movie genre where it's kind of like
sci-fi used to be back in the old days
what's up dave june we're not taking it
seriously
you know we're not examining which is
dumb because like horror
i kind of feel like that's a genre that
you can really explore
um
some kind of like emotions and like a
lot of [ __ ] that you can't really
explore
in other genres as easily
so
to kind of like put this in another
i don't know man like to kind of put it
in another kind of like box i guess is
like really [ __ ] up i don't know i
don't i don't like it
khan says jenny in your opinion what is
the best underrated
horror movie ever made oh underrated oh
man that's hard
god damn it there's so many
um i've actually done a lot of
them
on my horror movie review show
um if you want to talk about old ones
[ __ ] i don't know how like underrated
stuff is what was that one with the guy
who was sucking bringing back the dead
people
dead and buried dead and buried and
buried yeah that's a good one it's a
good one i kind of feel like that's one
that a lot of people like forget about
from the
early 80s
was like dead and buried it was kind of
like silent hill before silent hill
yeah that one's good
um
recently
underrated i think i just put up a
review of one
that man that really like that i really
liked a lot and that was a turkish movie
called baskin
baskin
was like i kind of feel like some people
kind of like denigrated a oh it's like a
turkish hellraiser
but
holy [ __ ] man there was so much other
stuff going on in that movie there was
that movie was kind of like one of those
ones it almost had like a david lynch
kind of vibe to it like in the first
half
and then it went like full
you know kind of hell razor like gore
fest in the second half
but man there was so much like kind of
mythological [ __ ] going on in that there
was oh it was there was all kind of [ __ ]
going on in that
um i think i mentioned it before but
like mungo if you like uh mockumentaries
or found footage that was a really good
one that was uh underrated i feel like
that not a lot of people talk about
back in the old days i'm trying to think
of like some old stuff
the innocence has everybody seen that
that was a you know creepy ass ghost
story
i don't know there's so much like [ __ ]
from the 70s and 80s i don't know it's
like bad
it's bad there are so many and i don't
really know
nowadays i kind of feel like everybody
talks about
all the underrated [ __ ] so i don't
really know how underrated stuff is one
i never mentioned is dead and buried
yeah that's good and that's one that's
on that's like pretty easy to get i
think it's on shutter i think it's on 2b
i think it's like you can see that
really just a weird flick
it is weird it is weird but it's good
though yeah
and i think that a lot of concepts that
they
went into it when did that come out 81
yeah right on time i think it was 81.
a lot of concepts that go into that
into that into that movie is kind of
like
[ __ ] that was picked up later on but
i kind of feel like that movie doesn't
get a lot of uh
credit for that
you know what i'm saying
you know kind of talking about the void
i don't know that one ooh
oh that's a good one
what's that about the void
was that came out and when 2016 2017
something like that
and it is a
kind of lovecraftian
you can tell that it was influenced by
the thing
uh
but yeah that was a really good one uh
if you've if you like the void also
watch the endless which i think is also
on uh shutter
which is not as gory but it's
kind of has that same like lovecraftian
cosmic horror kind of vibe to it
um but yeah the void was real real good
that was a really good movie
uh yeah hospital horror kind of asan
says void needs a review yeah that was
also really good and khan also brought
up the endless yeah
uh i really liked the endless
there's kind of like
man i don't know i was thinking about
lovecraftian
horror recently because i just
did i just recorded a review
i'm not gonna go into it right now
i just recorded a view of this [ __ ]
right here which i know some of you have
been waiting for so i'm gonna show you
this is going up sunday or monday
so everybody everybody that asked me
about it i finally like finished reading
yeah i don't think they can read it
house of leaves okay
i finally finished rereading it
and i just recorded a review of it today
it was like an hour long
i'm not real sure how coherent it was
because i don't like script anything i'm
just kind of like i read the [ __ ]
and
i just start talking about it like i do
on here
so
i'm just like talking about my feelings
about it
this book
i know you've never read this and you'd
probably just like think it was annoying
but
this book is like one of the most
what am i talking about okay so this is
like one of the most complex like
complicated this is like not even a book
it's like a whole
it's like a whole [ __ ] experience man
so
i had a hard time
because i told you guys when i did the
tbr at in january if you guys read like
watch my book reviews i don't know if
you do or not
but i said in january i said look i read
this a long time ago my friend gave
that book to me back in 2002 or some
[ __ ] like that
and i read it back then i'm like oh my
god this is one of the most mind-blowing
things i ever read
and i said i need to reread that one of
these days so when i started doing the
book reviews i said okay i'm going to
reread it but
it took me so long to do it because it's
so long and it's like it's so
dense
that
so i had to take like two weeks to do it
which is a long time for me
so finally finally today i recorded
a review of it and i don't even know
man i don't even know how good it is
because i was just kind of like like i
said i don't script anything
i read the [ __ ]
i read some [ __ ] about it i'm just kind
of like okay i'm just gonna talk
and we'll see how it comes out
it was an hour long but i don't really
know if i came to any kind of
conclusions about it but you know
i know some of you guys were waiting for
that [ __ ] because
victor says
tila says what you're doing casa please
okay so
if you're a patron i'll put i'm gonna
put it up it'll beat up on sunday
morning if you're not it'll be up on
monday morning
um
i don't know like i don't really feel
like
the thing about that book is like i
don't feel like i'm up to the task
i recorded a review of it sort of which
is like an hour long
but even still i don't really know if i
got to the bottom of the [ __ ]
um
[Music]
yeah tila's excited
victor says yeah i stopped reading it
when i got the er job i'm gonna start it
again soon it's one of those books that
i don't even like it's not even a book
man it's like
it's like an experience that's what i'm
saying that's why it took me so long to
get to it because i'm like i really need
some time i'd read it before but i
that's why i knew
you really need some time to like
sit with it
it's not a book
it's an art installation
so you have to
engage with it on its own level because
there's
lots of like [ __ ] going on in there
that's like not
that like transcends booktum if that
makes any sense
so
i don't know i don't i don't know if
what i talked about was like even
adequate but
i'll put it up later you'll see
uh victor says is the review safe from
spoilers it is not
so
sorry about that because victor hasn't
finished it
but
i don't know i don't i feel like
spoilers are maybe not even relevant
i don't know in this situation
it has a story but
there's so many other narratives going
on in it and there's so many other
theories swirling about it that i don't
really know if it's like relevant to i
don't really know i don't know
i'm just saying
but
maybe maybe victor finish it
and then come back and watch the review
because i think i did spoil some [ __ ]
about it like people that died and stuff
so
you might not wanna
i'm just saying
uh jay says does tom read much
not much anymore he does not no i'll
read stuff on the internet when i have
to doing research and learn how to work
things and [ __ ] reprogram stuff
but um
i kind of lost my gusto for [ __ ]
reading
novels especially after i had my
motorcycle uh wreck
because when i came out of my coma
i had a problem keeping my eyes going
across the line of print i'd raid like
this and then all of a sudden i'd go
back and read it again and i'd skip
lines and jump around and during that
time of my recovery [ __ ] i could read
sentences but i might have to read it
three or four times because my eyes
would move involuntarily to another line
[ __ ] frustrating as [ __ ]
and that took about a year for the for
that [ __ ] to stop doing that and then
during that time i was [ __ ] worried
about some of so many other things as i
got out of the habit of [ __ ] reading
books
um because i used to read them when i
was in the service too because you're
doing so much hurry up and waiting you'd
be [ __ ] reading [ __ ] you know
because you couldn't you know before
was before tablets you couldn't bring a
movie with you on a [ __ ] phone back
in those days you had to have a book
those [ __ ] get soggy too
[ __ ] get rained on
yeah they get rained on sometimes
but uh
yeah just haven't done a long time i i
don't really seem to have
the patience that i used to have khan's
asking me to do a review on the dune
book
i'd love to go back and read that book i
guess but
i'll read something i'll read something
i'll get halfway through it and then
something will distract me and i'll
[ __ ] put the book down and never
start it back up that's another thing
jenny's giving me books and i'll get
halfway through that [ __ ] and get get
[ __ ] sidetracked
you need discipline i need discipline
when it comes to that kind of stuff
again maybe i should just try to get
back into it the thing is is if i was
going to read
dune
there's a good chance i'd have to read
dude messiah and all the other books
i'm kind of a completist if i go off
into that we'll see that's a huge world
that makes [ __ ]
that's even bigger than tolkien
to get off into dune
there's just all kinds of [ __ ] in there
that's kind of similar to what happens
with this situation
um
there are a lot of like supplementary
materials
that you have to read yeah you don't
have to read it you can still enjoy it
but
there's a lot of supplementary materials
hubert frank hubert wrote her herbert
hubert herbert frank herbert he wrote
three or four of them
but then it was so popular
that there's like an expanse of like
extremely authentic
fan fiction
you know i mean like i think people have
the rights to write that
um that's how good they are it's not so
it's not really fan fiction so there are
other people writing that on that
and and this is over the decades so i
think there's like
at least 10 of those books out there
well it's just kind of like when
lovecraft was still alive if he had like
a bunch of
uh
dudes that he knew that were writers
that would write in his universe
yeah and that was kind of like okay
um
you know and like i said if you don't
want to like dip into that you don't
have to
but
if you want to like
get all [ __ ] into it you totally can
yeah
i'll tell you what uh the movie did so
well i'm wondering where the video games
are
because there was always video games for
dune and they're kind of like command
and conquer or red alert
like sim city with [ __ ] combat
mine and spice building [ __ ] i got one
of the best ones dune
dune emperor or emperor dune i think it
was called dune emperor i think is the
name of it
and uh i got a [ __ ] pc reserved just
for that game
this badass got cut scenes and
everything and it was from the late 90s
and it still holds up today
it's better than any of those command
conquer games
tila says i haven't seen dune yet i know
it's on hbo max but peeps are telling me
to see it on the big screen yeah see
that [ __ ] um yeah i would recommend
seeing it on a big screen because it is
a visual
great sound orgasm
yeah it's like it's beautiful beautiful
on the big i'm sure it's good on like
small green tea but i'd go into dolby
theater yeah we saw it in dolby and it's
like it's way way better
get right in the middle of that [ __ ]
dolby screen right behind the [ __ ]
right behind the uh
the uh the wheelchair [ __ ] seats
right behind the handicap scene that's
right
yeah
and um
it's real good storytelling i don't know
if you've seen the original movie the uh
the dino de laurentiis one which i love
that one too
this one is what you doing pope
it's a worthy successor to that it's a
lot bigger scope a lot bigger budget um
a lot more detail
it's a little bit more like the book i
would say in certain ways
from what i remember the book
um it does seem like a lot more book
faithful but some stuff is left out yeah
or some stuff is minimized that that's
more than left out minimized yeah that
story is so complicated and the way it's
written
the way he wrote is kind of vague it
leaves a lot to the imagination he's
talking about details
that some people maybe wouldn't wouldn't
be all that
interested in
what
frank was a he was basically a scientist
i think he was an ecologist if i
remember correctly
trying to remember what it was but he
knew how to make realistic ecosystems
and stories
he wasn't really pulling that [ __ ] out
of his ass he was talking about humans
and human nature and what doom was
really about there was an example
of a futuristic mankind that still had
retained its humanity
it had defeated an ai attempts to
overthrow humans
basically what it is they had defeated
they had defeated [ __ ] sky net
and computers were totally illegal it
was not in their religion
to have our ai
so humans had to develop mental powers
and mental abilities and disciplines
to compensate for the lack of computers
and ai
because they were a threat
there's a world very different than
today it progressed but it didn't
progress the way you think it did it its
political system was basically monarchy
it had
it had [ __ ] um what do you call them
monopolies
and religions
and it was a good example of humans
who had uh what's a good way to put it
who were not controlled by governments
per se they were controlled more by
cultures and religions and traditions
and taboos
which that's another way to do it that's
the way the middle ages were there just
wasn't government control it was just
cultural control and they were all
different these and there weren't any
and what was unique about it is that
it's a science with the only science
fiction series
i can think of that doesn't have any
aliens
in terms of like intergalactic [ __ ] no
aliens they never found any aliens
they're just everybody is some kind of a
human and humans that had evolved into
things that were kind of not all that
human they found animals and plants
alien animals and plants but no alien
civilizations
as far as i can remember and i think the
only
thing in the lore
is that the lord the in in dune lord
they said that [ __ ] uh they found
some ancient ruins on a planet
sometime in the past
and they were so old they didn't know if
they were human ruins of a forgotten
world the humans once inhabited
or if it was extraterrestrial and it was
still the scientists still hadn't the
archaeologists and scientists hadn't
decided it was still up in the air so it
was weird
a program about interstellar [ __ ]
space and no aliens
very unique and daring decision tila
said i saw clips of the old one
never saw the full movie of dune or read
the book yet so i'm going with fresh
eyes it probably helps if you read the
book but you don't
i don't think you um
have to
no you could just go see it it's pretty
it's pretty straightforward it helps if
you read the book obviously but
i think it's pretty straightforward even
if you haven't read it because i've read
it but when i was a teenager so like a
long time ago most people going to see
this movie have have seen the deal
deodorant the david lynch
that he took his name off of yeah
there's a couple different edits of that
um
there was uh uh uh an edit made out of
the tv release which had a bunch of
extra stuff and then the movie released
and they i think they call it the sand
writer a worm writer
[ __ ] edit which is just done by a fan
but it's [ __ ] really good
um
then there's a tv release that's about
45 minutes longer that's kind of
ponderous but it does have good [ __ ] in
it that movie was a disaster you dune is
not movable in one movie that was the
problem they tried to get it all into
one movie and somehow compete with star
wars if they were going to compete with
star wars they should have planned for a
trilogy and it would easily be generally
depending on the novel and
honestly um usually like sci-fi in
particular
horror maybe like lesser
you're gonna try to put a whole novel
into one movie
yeah you're gonna have a bad time yeah
and the dune the dune novel is like on
par with the old testament the way it's
written it's like you're reading
something from another planet way in the
future ten thousand years in the future
well they say it's a year ten thousand
the year ten thousand one ninety one but
the problem is is that the calendar that
they're on is about another ten year
thousand years ahead of us so it's
twenty thousand years in the future
yeah
that's a little yeah
it needs
room to breathe you can't cram that into
one movie right but like i said no i i
think it's good that like somebody's
doing it now because
finally
uh people have figured out
look we can't take one novel especially
one that sprawling
and put it into one two hour movie yeah
that's not gonna work out and it's like
um
at the at the pace the movie's going
there must be three movies it's because
the story well there are they're gonna
do a second one for sure yeah um that
that's already been greenlighted but
we'll see you could finish it in one
more movie you could but i would think
that probably more like three because i
kind of feel like the first half this
movie is two and a half hours long and
they did about the first half of the
book
about
there's a lot of stuff that happens in
the sieges but there's some stuff they
left out yeah there is some stuff there
yeah and what was what was weird about
it is that
as far as it got and they still haven't
showed fade ralpha
which
yeah i saw uh
dom noble he kind of like did a
breakdown of this and he's like where
was fade yeah fade should have been in
there because in the original movie i
would recommend seeing the origin see
the original movie you'd like it it
doesn't make a goddamn lick of sense
because it does it sort of does but it
it's cool looking real cool looking and
it's kind of
it's if you haven't read the book it
will make absolutely that [ __ ] crazy it
will make absolutely no sense
but that movie can give a little bit
more context to what you're seeing in
this one but yeah i in a way like if you
don't want to read the book because it
is a big commitment i get that but it's
like um you can watch that movie it will
make no sense to you but like when you
see like the new movie it makes a lot
more it will make a lot more sense yeah
yeah if you don't like read the book but
like i said
i read the book but a long time ago i
was like a teenager
the movie version of the david lynch one
does not have the
the the prologue or the epilogue that
the tv version had you can see that on
youtube and it's animated and it's just
narrated there's a lot of narration in a
lot of the [ __ ]
that's what the one of the things that i
liked about this new version yeah is
that
um
the 80s version it had like this
narration
which i normally don't like because that
usually means
you know that means we didn't do our job
like when we were doing the movie and
it's like nobody knows what's going on
um
so the old one had that and i still
didn't know what was going on even
though i had read the book
i understood it i mean i got it but it
it wasn't super clear it was kind of
like all over the place well this new
movie yeah did not have that and i still
could follow it no problem yeah there
are some people that have even mentioned
it though when we talked about it in our
early [ __ ] kind of review of it with
non-spoiler reviews
some
subscribers of ours
couldn't understand why certain things
had happened and it's because they
didn't talk about the butlerian jihad
and that was when they destroyed they
overthrew
the intelligent machines and the men who
controlled machines and all the
computers yeah that was the one and that
was another thing that dom noble got
into he's like they didn't really talk
about the men
like they just kind of like referred to
them but they didn't like say what they
were right or why they existed or but in
a way like i i don't know i already knew
that because i'm pretty familiar with
dune lore
so it didn't bother me that was left out
but if you don't know anything about
dune lore yet that might be like some
kind of like who's that dude see one of
the things that's weird about this
science fiction is that
they have all this technology space
travel on everything they don't have
guns
and they don't even have any cut so
you're like well what the [ __ ] they're
fighting with swords and stuff
and we're dark guns
and it's because
they had these shields
and they couldn't have computers
uh as part of it
they had shields
that you couldn't the harder you hit it
the more it resisted so
the best way to get through the shield
was with a a sharp knife and it but it
had to be moving slowly the slower it
was going
the more it would go through the shield
because it wouldn't like register right
now they had things that were like laser
guns or ray guns but you couldn't shoot
a shielded person
if you shot a person that had a shield
the shield would be conducted down the
damn laser and blow up you and your gun
and the dude that you shot so it'll just
be a massive explosion so it was
dangerous to shoot anybody that had a
shield with any kind of laser so you'll
see lasers but they don't use them
against people they only use them
against
ships and [ __ ]
or lasers and [ __ ] particle beams and
stuff because all that [ __ ] was real
real risky to use
but so it's
in the book you would know but when
you're watching this on tv it doesn't
make any sense like why are why didn't
they shoot them they can't
you know but it's not it hasn't been
explained
uh so the technology is not really
explained and then
they got helicopters that have dragonfly
wings that flap
yeah that's
which i don't know how you do that
without a computer but they figured it
out
oh they could also bend time and space
and
but like i said i kind of feel like at
this point in time
most people that would go see the dune
movie know all that you know all the
dune lore so i kind of feel like they
don't really need to waste a lot of time
saying hey in the future this that and
the other right i kind of feel like
they're just kind of like leaving it to
everyone's
like look if you don't know then go find
out it's there's the internet it's the
21st century yeah uh you can find out
what happened in the book you don't we
don't really need to show it yeah which
i get that like i respect that he well
he's respecting his audience's
intelligence
uh so a lot of stuff he didn't really
need to like spell out and like i said i
like that and there's if you don't know
what's going on there's some creepy [ __ ]
you know what i mean they just show they
talk about the solder car who are the
imperial troops the emperor's private
mercenaries and they show them [ __ ]
having this big religious ceremony and
they're out there going oh
and they're [ __ ] stealing that fruit
singing and they're [ __ ] sacrificing
dudes who are laying upside down and
their bloods going into the ground what
the [ __ ] is going on here
and there's no real explanation of what
in the book these dudes are on a planet
called salacious secundus that is a
[ __ ] maximum security prison
and
like
most of them die on it and those who
live are kind of trained up and they
forced to fight each other to the death
and the survivors end up being saudi car
which are these mercenaries that are
allowed to not only leave the planet and
serve the emperor as terrorists and
terror troops they also get paid so they
have a [ __ ] [ __ ] ton of [ __ ] money
and so that's the only way off that
planet or to have anything is to [ __ ]
just becoming total [ __ ] badasses
and they just show them falling out of
the sky you know what the hell what how
why are you falling out they had any
gravity stuff they were like
paratroopers they'd come down with
knives and try to stab your just [ __ ]
like that it wouldn't make sense to a
young kid that doesn't know the lore
they're like why don't they have guns
here so
the technology didn't allow it
you know although like i said i kind of
feel like in the context of the movie
you could just kind of roll with it yeah
knife fighting and armor and stuff
maybe maybe that's just me like coming
at it because i read the book a long
time ago and i've seen the other
adaptation of it so i kind of know like
where we're coming from
connor ozilon asks jenny got another
question which horror movie made the
most impact on cinema
and changed the perception of horror ooh
there have been so many
i kind of feel like but well back in the
old days
you kind of had [ __ ] like
nosferatu or cabinet of dr caligari
which were kind of like
coming at it more like
um
subjective kind of point of view we're
gonna like show you something that is
filmic but also
subjective it's not in it's not
realistic we're we're showing you
something that is
based on someone's individual perception
of something you know what i mean so
expressionism except essentially so you
had that you also had you know [ __ ] that
happened in the 60s with psycho with
peeping tom
where we're going more into
not necessarily sympathizing with
the villain
but
maybe introducing um
more ambiguity
into a film where
i kind of feel like prior to that
and this is you know not across the
board but prior to that i kind of feel
like there was a very like black and
white this is the good guy this is the
bad guy
with the advent of something like
peeping tom or psycho
um you got something a little more a lot
more ambiguous where this is a serial
killer but also they have
sympathetic uh aspects to them they are
still a human being
and um an audience can still relate to
them even though they are still a killer
which like to me
is a lot better because it's a lot more
realistic and it's a lot more
complicated so i kind of feel like that
was a big
that was kind of a big thing in horror
like introducing that aspect to
movie
you know movie making i guess
um other than that i don't know like
it depends on what subgenre you're
talking about are you talking about
slasher movies
uh in which case
you know bay of blood
black christmas that's slasher movies
um
i don't know it psychological horror
like i said you talking about psycho
again
there's i don't know there's a lot of
different things there's a lot of
different things that kind of like came
about and i don't know if i'm like sober
enough to
to expound upon it
but are you getting hungry
kind of let's go ahead and shut it down
now well wait a minute wait a minute
okay i'm like
okay
where where i don't know i'm protecting
you from stumbling over yourself and
forgetting where you are
oh well gee thank you yeah see how it is
kind of vassaline uh oscar perez has the
exorcist yeah that was kind of like i
think the exorcist
was
maybe the first example of horror movie
as
blockbuster
because
we kind of touched upon this earlier but
horror as a genre and also sci-fi to a
lesser extent
has always been seen as kind of like
a lesser
genre that's always kind of like oh well
that's the bee movies that's the [ __ ]
the kids are going to see
and for a long time like in the 50s and
stuff that was kind of like the audience
that it was targeted toward we're just
gonna make these dumb
big bug movies roger corman was doing
that [ __ ] we're gonna make like these
movies with
you know giant ducks and [ __ ] like that
with girls and bikinis and whatnot
because that's who's going to see it so
i kind of feel like until the 1970s just
all the exorcists came out
nobody really took
horror as a genre seriously
except well the europeans did
but in the us that really didn't happen
because you had you know you had like
nicholas roy he was making like do look
now which was a very adult movie and
also kind of a horror movie
but
i don't know i i just kind of feel like
that wasn't
i kind of feel like horror and sci-fi
were
teenager
genres
until the 1970s and then you had the
exorcist
and it was a massive massive hit
and it also got nominated for a bunch of
oscars and stuff like that so it's oh my
god so actually adults are going to see
this [ __ ] and you can approach adult
uh themes
with uh you know in a horror context
which i kind of feel like hadn't really
been done up to that point at least in
that way
so until the 1970s i kind of feel like
horror was seen as
a kids genre which is kind of a shame
but
so you know like i said i guess the
exorcist was kind of like a big the
game-changing thing because because it
was a thing where
that was a huge hit everybody came to
see it
it got nominated it was actually a film
as you say
it was a film
um
because it had a lot of stuff going on
other than being a horror movie so it
kind of transcended its genre okay um
um
khan said that his wife saw a dude and
really didn't enjoy it because she
didn't know any of the backstory and
thought it was pretty complicated
and couldn't grasp the the idea of
like sword fighting and knife fighting
in the future where you have spaceships
and ray guns and [ __ ] and i i kind of
thought that that would happen um she
said she didn't really like it she
couldn't follow it um
i kind of figured that would happen not
giving
the audience any kind of backstory kind
of like the original did
just the way people think you know what
i mean you're mixing futurism with
[ __ ] retro-ism it's retro-futuristic
you're like why isn't there guns
guns were totally obsolete so were ray
guns kinda they're too dangerous to use
so everything had to be done kind of the
old-fashioned way technology had
canceled out a lot of high-tech weapons
and nuclear weapons were
were banned every they used them later
on in the book though
um
guided missiles they had them a little
bit and bombs
but they didn't work too well against
dudes that were shielded only way to go
through a shield is they had a dart gun
that would kind of any gravity that
would slip forward and when it hit a
shield it had a screw tip on it and it
would slowly try to rotate and dig its
way through a shield and once it got
through it would dig through the human
they also had poison gases they used
that a lot of poison
because it was only because poison could
go through the shield with the oxygen so
it's good thinking it's good thinking
it's just that
you have to i think that they should
have
talked about that the butlerian jihad
and the [ __ ]
mentats
because mentats were human computers
raised up out of a dead body brought
back to life
that's a weird concept
well like i said it's all on what you
bring to it i was not bothered
by
the lack of
not over explaining stuff because like i
said i read dune as a teenager i've seen
the david lynch dino de laurentiis one
so i kind of like knew all the lore
um so to me it didn't really seem
uh
like they were leaving stuff out i was
just kind of like look i already know
all that stuff so it's like good that
they're not wasting time on it now if
somebody's coming in
completely
not knowing anything about dude that's
what i was thinking
i don't know i
it's hard for me to say that's a those
are some added layers to add interest
you'll be like oh man these dudes are
the living dead basically some of these
dudes are believing yeah like i'm kind
of like a big advocate of
one show don't tell which like i said
that's they teach you that in any good
screenwriting class
if you go see a movie and there's some
[ __ ] going on and there's like you don't
really get it and it's just kind of like
not really explained
that's good because you leave some
mystery for the people to be like what
was going on with that and then like
you're kind of engaging with it
yeah you know interactively
so the lynch version did that though
sometimes it's just there was so much of
it like the scene where men tap potter
veriz was [ __ ] making the juice of
sefu and drinking it and [ __ ] doing
his little mental ritual about the the
lips acquire stains and then the mind
acquired speed by my will alone my foot
was
like what the [ __ ] is that dude doing it
getting juiced up to [ __ ] think man
think thinking fast as a [ __ ]
doing these huge calculations in his
head
but see nowadays nowadays that was weird
too that he was evil nowadays because a
movie is not just a movie let's be
honest
it's the movie but it's also all the
other online stuff that's going on
around it so there's all of this other
like supplemental material
um if you're interested enough in that
movie
to look into the [ __ ]
i kind of feel like the movie should
just kind of like concentrate on
the visual [ __ ] and the story and
everything don't do too much backstory
leave some mystery
don't over explain anything don't expose
it
um if people are interested enough
to look into the [ __ ]
then
put it on a website
they'll they'll look it up later you
don't really need to like
[ __ ] up the movie with all that [ __ ] i
don't know t i'm thinking maybe you
ought to watch the david lynch [ __ ]
movie first
or read the book
it takes time although the read the book
is very it's that's it's very long i
watch that david lynch movie because it
adds other layers the david lynch movie
i look i love david lynch
the book is good the movie
even though i've read the book yeah the
movie to me makes no goddamn sense yeah
but and like i said and this is coming
from some of the i love david lynch look
i love lost highway makes complete sense
to me mulholland drive makes complete
sense to me dune makes no sense to me at
all
um and i you know it makes sense to me i
mean it does but it's like i've read the
book i know what's going on kind of but
it's like it's really the problem with
the lynch dune is that the edit is a
very uneven speed yeah i think that's
what it is it takes its time in the
beginning it sets a lot of things then
it starts to speed up because they're
running out of [ __ ] time
yeah and then it gets started they're
trying to cram it into one they're
trying to cram it all in and they're
using narration to get the [ __ ] which
was the first mistake yeah well
i think they had enough to make a
six-hour [ __ ] movie enough footage
and and evidently somebody's pieced a
lot of that together because the tv
version was a lot longer and there have
been people that have pieced it pieced
it together into a badass edits that
tell most of the story
but some of the shots look kind of
cheesy
of the of the [ __ ] spaceship it was
84. yeah spaceships flying over it so
you can tell us some of the shots
weren't complete spaceships flying over
and dropping bombs on the [ __ ] the
eutrades [ __ ] city
and it looks like they have something
out of a godzilla movie with the
helicopters flying yeah i mean look
that's how bad it looked in certain
shots but they're just trying to
piece the whole story together out of
what was they didn't really have
the
uh
the budget of the time they didn't have
the budget they didn't have the time
they didn't have the resources yeah to
bring something that epic
to the screen but the first the the
lynch the lynch theatrical release has
badass
costumes it does a pretty good job of
painting the basic world it tells the
story just that in a very uneven speed
that's the problem
yeah it is kind of strangely yes
i think that's the main problem i have
with it is that it's like the pace of it
is very strange
but like i said they were trying to cram
a lot of
information
still holds up says do did the
director's cut of it
yeah we've watched the director's cut
like i said
and i get that like david lynch
and you know you guys know i'm a big
david lynch fan
um him having to do dune
is a weird um
that's still a weird
combo to me
t you can go on you can go on youtube
and watch the prologue
to the dune television release for it i
think it's about five minutes it is
admittedly a complicated universe yeah
and that'll give you a little bit of
background about the butlerian jihad
this is happening after that [ __ ] and
kyle was saying the butler and jihad
would have been a badass movie that they
think that's why they're trying to
revive this well they're doing a prequel
yeah the prequels should be the
butlerian jihad and that would be badass
i mean i heard they were humans versus
a.i and big tech
they had enslaved humanity and they'd
gotten weak and lazy because robots and
ai served them
and then
it was so protective like an
overprotective mother they couldn't do
anything and then when they tried when
they wanted freedom the robots basically
just started to just like literally
kind of like
fight against them getting rid of the
robots you couldn't get rid of the
robots and the robots didn't want you to
do anything
and then there were evil men behind it
to make sure that that was happening so
they could make all the power and money
and then there were some ai computers
that were helping the humans that their
intelligence was
superior to a human and they were trying
to hijack i guess you could say the big
tech oligarchs who made them so
it was like
kind of like a softer version of [ __ ]
skynet
kind of they weren't trying to wipe
everybody out they were just
infantilizing humanity so once they
finally got rid of them they said that's
where a bunch of dummies yeah
after they got have to be able to do
that the outlaw they made it into all
their religions kind of had a
commandment is now shall not make a come
shall not make a computer in the in the
form of the mind of man that was like
that was like yeah so everything would
be like human like everything had to be
analog yeah and there was nothing but
[ __ ] there was a bunch of religions
and philosophies in schools took over
and
and and corporations
captain blair says
pukestaratu
when pookie's toy dracula bites her yeah
look you guys
i don't know like you guys saw this
earlier i showed this elsa sent her all
of these halloween toys
she has this crankly dracula
for whatever reason she loves these
feathers
this dracula is like laying in the floor
and pookie just like licks the feathers
she's like yeah she's like so weird
um somebody says wait
victor says mulholland drive is on my
watch list [ __ ]
[ __ ]
mulholland drive is one of my favorite
movies ever
um
[Music]
but you have to watch it
how many times did i watch it before i
figured it out probably well second time
second or third time i watched i figured
it out
um it's not really that hard to figure
out in hindsight
but
mulholland drive is so
beautifully
constructed
and just so it's it's not all that
complicated to figure out it's not like
super like
you know i don't know it's it's not like
a super puzzle or anything once you know
like one thing about it
everything kind of like falls into place
all right see you ready g t is check it
out bye tea okay um but after you kind
of like get that key to it it's like
every single thing
makes total sense
i'm almost kind of like in awe
i don't know like i'm a big fan of david
lynch because it seems like everything
that he does is like so instinctive
and yet
it still comes out like this big like
complex like he
thought a lot about it
but he doesn't seem to that makes me
really angry
because that like i don't have that
like i have to like
consciously think of this stuff but he
doesn't really seem to everything just
seems like [ __ ]
it just seems to come to him uh
you know just
like that and it's just like i don't i
don't know like
that makes me angry but like mulholland
drive
the first time you watch it
it won't make any sense
but
the more times you watch it the more
sense it will make i promise
seriously watch it lost highway is good
too
and lost highway i kind of feel like i
just did a review of it not too long ago
lost highway i kind of feel like was the
test run
from mulholland drive mulholland drive i
kind of feel like is his masterpiece
inland empire is good too but i kind of
feel like inland empire was his thing
where it's like oh look i'm gonna take
like the david lynch thing and i'm just
gonna like [ __ ] go
ham with it
um so
that one is like three hours long and
there's all kind of crazy [ __ ] going on
in that and i love that movie but
it's a i don't know i i kind of feel
like it's a little too much lost highway
is like not enough
inland empire is too much
mulholland drive is just right you know
what i mean it's just right it's just
weird enough
to be
cool to like people but it's still like
accessible enough
that
people that aren't super into like this
weird like [ __ ]
you know thing can still get into it
so i kind of feel like that was kind of
like the [ __ ]
you know what i mean it's it just hit
the right spot i love lost highway i
love inland empire but it's just kind of
like
he just got it right right in the middle
it's just really really good that's one
of my favorite movies actually ever
maybe actually maybe my favorite where'd
you go if you want to eat
yeah yeah i'm going to start cooking
tila says i think i'll give the new one
a look i'll read a little bit about it
before i go in to get some main
character detail
yeah yeah it's honestly like i said it's
hard for me to say because i read the
book i saw the original movie so i was
kind of like familiar with the lore
i don't know somebody just coming into
it with not knowing anything
it's you talking it might be a little
complicated following but maybe not
maybe not i would recommend watching the
directors cut a [ __ ] the david lynch
version because that's the basic outline
of the story is there and there are some
some background
that would be a good that's a good movie
uh this one's a different a different
take on it the look is a little
different it's the same basic story just
not all of the story doesn't finish it
you'll know kind of what happens from
this movie how it'll end but just the
way that they do it is dif i don't know
it depends on how you want to do it um
you're talking about a movie
based upon a [ __ ] series of books
that a lore that's [ __ ] many times
the size of the lord of the rings
it's a lot bigger yeah it's like a math
and
and it this movie kind of does it in its
own style because a lot of times in
those books nothing is really described
how they look how things look so you can
kind of
i like the way david lynch did did the
way it looked
you know
yeah i mean i will admit that movie is
um inscrutable in a lot of ways but the
visuals of it look fantastic yeah the
outfits and the uniforms oh yeah
just the dialogue it's most of the
dialogue of the lynch film is and gotta
say uh denis villeneuve he put he picked
up a lot of stuff from the david lynch
one
yeah rightfully so cause he's like yeah
he's like i like the look of that so he
was gonna use it it doesn't look it it
doesn't look anything like the david
lynch one
um but he did
he did use a couple of uh things from
that
which you know
uh oscar is laughing at me ha ha jenny
doesn't want to call the first dune
movie the david lynch one well
it is the david lynch one but
david lynch
won he didn't write it
and two
after he did it they took it away from
him and made it like not like he wanted
it cut a lot of it out and he was mad
yeah so
i know he directed it but i mean most
cuts of it still say alan smithy on it
because he didn't want his name on it i
would look at the david lynch director's
cut
yeah that one's better
it's still inscrutable but it's better
it's no it's not inscrutable it you can
understand it
it's kind of like the edit is in some
ways kind of like watching one of those
movies about the old testament and it's
kind of supposed to be
because dune is in a way supposed to be
like you're hearing about people from
the ancient past in your religion kinda
yeah the way the way the books are kind
of written
they're in sometimes it feels like
they're talking about something that is
happening in the past but it's 20 000
years in the future
but it doesn't it it depends i guess it
just it has a very antique
religious feel to it that's a good way
to put it
they're all religious in the book but
they're not the religions we know
they're future religions
well and like i said it's something that
sci-fi writers do a lot is that they
kind of like take the present day or the
past and they kind of like extrapolate
that into the future
and say like well what would it be like
if
you know 20 000 years from now
everything had blah blah blah
and so that's kind of like what you're
getting
yeah um
i don't know like i said it's hard for
me to say
i kind of feel like this movie did a
good job of
building the world so that you didn't
necessarily
have to have read the book or
necessarily have to have seen the
original movie but
it would help
yeah because maybe there was some [ __ ] i
don't know maybe
because i did see the old movie and i
did read the book so i don't really know
how somebody that was like a complete
noob coming at it i don't know if it
would just be completely like
not understanding hey captain blair did
you see um did you see star trek
continues they did uh
they did the episode
with the the second half of [ __ ] kirk
and spock
[ __ ] in the mirror universe that was
a [ __ ] badass [ __ ] episode i
forgot what it was called mirror mirror
no uh the fairest of them all that's
what it's called yeah it's on youtube
you can watch it for free
real good mirror episode
victor kirk when he went back victor
makes the point that star wars is a
religious movie and it takes place in
the past yeah the same kind of thing
yeah same kind of thing
so dune is not like that weird in that
regard no and i kind of feel like
this new movie really does um do a lot
visually to kind of just fill you in on
the world without you necessarily having
to know a lot about it
yeah uh yeah so that's good man you
should see the rest of them man that
whole all stc is great i love that
series
i actually want that [ __ ] on blu-ray
you can download it in blu-ray quality
and print out the [ __ ] covers and
everything
yeah they're not a well they're not
allowed to know how to sell them
because it's yeah it's non-profit
because it's you know and [ __ ] i hope
i hope once [ __ ] cbs [ __ ] gets rid
of that [ __ ] stupid star trek they're
making now i'd like [ __ ] um
star trek continues team
to go and start doing
the [ __ ] before or after the wrath of
khan period they've got the [ __ ] sets
and the [ __ ] uniforms
that in between those movies that would
be badass
well yeah they could do a whole kind of
like yeah
[ __ ] man yeah that's such an expansive
universe yeah you could do so much with
it yeah what happened before wrath of
khan that'd be a good one
trey says i actually love titanic people
make fun of me for it but i love it
um
i remember really liking i've only seen
it like once or twice i remember really
liking it
but i haven't seen in a long time
yeah khan says that hollywood needs to
hire us yeah actually we don't need
hollywood
we should just do all i'll come up with
my own [ __ ] come up with our own [ __ ]
[ __ ] crowd source that [ __ ] and
[ __ ] uh hire guys uh from like
[ __ ] what [ __ ] man we got listeners
that are [ __ ] making gina carano's
movie and [ __ ] [ __ ] um
guy went to the [ __ ] military academy
with brian hackett
and uh he's done a lot of crustal movies
[ __ ] bone tomahawk [ __ ]
[ __ ] uh
what's that uh vfw
just need to fall in with some of those
dudes and we'll make some [ __ ] our
own [ __ ]
our own [ __ ] sci-fi well yeah and to
be honest if i'm going to do something i
would rather create my whole
own universe i don't really want to do
and like no shame to people that want to
do fanfic and stuff but it's like i
don't really want to play in somebody
else's
universe i would rather come make your
own [ __ ] i would do something like that
video game with that [ __ ] called [ __ ]
warhammer or what's the [ __ ] one with
the religious dudes going through space
and [ __ ] with the [ __ ] crazy ass
armor
what's the name of that video game
uh not gears of war warcraft or what was
it yeah i'll have to look at it again
there's just these [ __ ] roided out
big [ __ ] just yelling all the
time in armor with the spaceships in
with gigantic [ __ ] war hammers and
laser guns and [ __ ]
something like that where they're on
religious crusade through space
to do some [ __ ] that was just crazy by
today's standards like bring the lord's
word to other aliens and [ __ ] to make
them con convert
and it's just crazy [ __ ] you know or the
mirror universe type [ __ ] from star trek
but that's license see you can't do it
but you can make your own [ __ ] like i
said make your own [ __ ] make your own
[ __ ] i like i said i don't i don't like
the idea of playing in someone else's
universe i would rather like make up my
own stuff i'm not really super into
sci-fi i like horror books
calling it space conquistadors yeah
yeah that's right you have aztecs and
conquistadors in space
they're descendants
it's the descendants of the mexican
empire
in another [ __ ] universe
that's what it is
that he had in an alternate universe
the spanish empire goes to mesoamerica
the
they [ __ ]
cause an industrial revolution hundreds
of years early
and the mexican empire becomes a
high-tech space-faring
[ __ ]
[ __ ] civilization by by the 1800s and
they're in the 1800s going through
[ __ ] space how about that
what okay yeah it's like half spain and
half [ __ ] aztec sorry i stopped lit
yeah she she's passing out she's no i'm
not passing out i was just like reading
other people's comments yeah um oscar
says
i saw mulholland drive high the first
time ooh i would not recommend that
uh and the winky's diner scene screwed
me up honestly
the winkie's diner scene in mulholland
drive
is
one of the most unsettling things i've
ever seen and i can't really
i can put my finger on why but i can't
exactly put my finger on one you know
what i'm talking about i wrote like a
whole blog post about this
and i said that um
there's a lot of [ __ ]
that is not even in horror movies
that
creeps me out more than horror movies
and the winky's diner scene in
mulholland drive is one of those and i'm
not really sure
what it is and i think that's kind of
why
that makes it scary so i was very happy
to see that there was like this list
that was done i can't remember who did
it but it was like some kind of thing
it's like oh the 50s scariest scenes
whatever and they put winky's diner
number one and i was like thank you i'm
[ __ ] vindicated because for a long
time i thought i was the only person
that was like really really
[ __ ] freaked out by that [ __ ]
even though i couldn't explain why
because of like if you explained it to
somebody it's not scary but if you watch
it
it's really really scary and nobody
knows why it's scary it just is it just
is and
that's why i love david lynch because he
cut he [ __ ] he can do that [ __ ]
yeah i'm going to make this [ __ ] scared
nobody can explain why it's scary it's
just scary
oscar's saying listen to susan the as
per your conversation they were great
yeah i don't know what years she
listened to she was around for a long
time also check out the creatures she
was in that band too yeah that was like
her offshoot band susie the banshees are
[ __ ] great man um
what my favorite album of there is
probably juju yeah um that's a great one
uh what's that what's the one that has
cities and dust on it uh
what's the [ __ ] name of that [ __ ] it
came out in like [ __ ] early 80s but
that was a good one too all the mexican
guys in there [ __ ] loving my space
aztec idea yeah see what it is when the
spaniards get down there in the 1500s
they're digging around those temples and
they find out that all that aztec [ __ ]
was alien that it was that there were
some aliens there before that's what all
that and then it causes this industrial
revolution to happen see
and then they all kind of merge together
and then they re-invade europe and take
that over and becomes part of the aztec
empire see
there's like a counter invasion and then
there's this huge boom
so it's kind of like
europe and the aztecs and then they take
over all of south america and all of
[ __ ] europe and it all combines into
one thing it's a space-faring [ __ ]
people flying around trying to find
quetzalcoatl [ __ ] sacrificing people
blood sacrifice making aliens pay the
blood debt all that kind of [ __ ] put all
it would be [ __ ] wild man all the
spaceships would look like [ __ ]
quetzalcoatl [ __ ]
feathered serpents and [ __ ] it'd be
[ __ ] great man it'd be great
because if he mix the motif would be
like
par it'd be futuristic but it would be
[ __ ] aztec and spanish all [ __ ]
happened to them armor and [ __ ] with
feathers on it and [ __ ] you could
have the jaguar [ __ ] soldiers and
eagle soldiers and all that you'd have
all those cultures combined into one
thing and would be like star trek but it
would be like the mirror universe they'd
all be like badasses yeah and they'd be
religious it'd be weird
and you'd have like catholicism merged
into it too
into the religion i think it would work
out
price sell a bunch man probably your
price [ __ ] would probably sell in
central and south america [ __ ] like
sell like hot cakes
because you know and it had the [ __ ] in
spanish
in spanish yeah
spanish and the hotel
the hottle they have both those words in
there make that [ __ ] authentic
all right that's all i'm saying trey
reminded me that the elm was called
tinderbox thank you i do have that on uh
cassette i'd forgotten the name of it
but thank you very much for reminding me
uh october 8th says i want to go to that
diner i don't know if it's still there
or not i'm pretty sure it's on sunset
boulevard or it was back in the day
uh get a cheeseburger fries man that
[ __ ] i don't know what it is about
that scene man it's like the day
time just two guys talking at a table
that whole scene where he goes like yeah
i had this nightmare it was about you
and like you were standing like right
over there and then like like this whole
thing where like he's later standing
over there oh i don't know that freaks
me out it's like and honestly like the
whole end of the scene where they go out
in the back and like the [ __ ]
creepy like [ __ ] monster bomb like
pops out from behind the [ __ ]
dumpster that's scary but like
everything leading up to that like
creeps me out more than that does
you know what i mean it's just i don't
know that whole scene is like [ __ ]
creepy to me
and i i can't explain
what it is but that's why it's scary
because it's like i can't explain why
it's scary it just is
i don't know like weirds me out
um yeah so where are we now
october 8th says uh [ __ ] dude sounds
cool i have a ship
okay constantly gonna put his poncho on
he's ready we're gonna put okay we're
all putting ponchos on yeah they're all
getting ready to go to space somebody
says yeah man we took over the world
let's go ahead and go to space that's
how it should happen and you go to the
space in the eighteen hundreds
all right but the technical in like us
in like a steam punk no no no the 1800s
will still be futuristic because the
industrial revolution happens in the
1500s
and it's been jump started by alien
technology all right that they that that
that that the mexicans had in those damn
temples because it turns out those
temples were extraterrestrially inspired
say so that's what jumped the [ __ ]
jump the technology ahead
a hundred years right there
so
the the the the uh the the new
aztec
18. we're gonna fly like
chichen itza or whatever yeah
version of 1800 a d is more like
2
200. it's like that
all right that's that's what level it's
at they're 200 years ahead of us right
now because the [ __ ] happened back in
the 1500s
and they had some alien technology see
so started it off
yeah the spaniards and the [ __ ] aztec
priests figured it out together how that
[ __ ] worked say
i had to make up some kind of a mcguffin
you know to explain it it might have
been a book
it might have been like a book
some kind of a book about technology
that the alias left behind
yeah
all right and actually the book might be
greek
it could be
that that [ __ ] quetzalcottle or uh
what was his name [ __ ] um google car
google con this ancient greek the same
guy that makes your dreams dude makes my
drinks
he had it and that's what how he taught
me they said that cool taught him how to
make all that stuff he had an alien book
yeah that the aliens gave him when he
was over in greece see and he got he got
marooned down there
in mexico and he uh well not in mexico
be someone like
like the pages of the book being made
out of some kind of like weird alien
metal it's gonna be it's not even a real
book it's a hologram of a book sure
that's what i'm thinking that's what it
is it's like a chip like a sith holocron
you [ __ ] do like that
like that well i don't know i kind of
feel like i like the way it still like
looks like a book though
okay well yeah it's got it looks it's uh
it's it's got pages but it's just
holograms of a page yeah okay just like
that yeah and it's got science because i
like that old school kind of science and
[ __ ] thank you victor jenny i say yellow
pic of my space aztec tattoo on facebook
messenger i'm waiting okay all right
yeah
yeah
yeah
contest the seven voices of cuckoo
that's going to be our movie
you guys yeah that's going to be a break
yeah
yeah
yeah and and in the aztec future they do
they do have [ __ ] goth checks and
it's all they all have the [ __ ] um
did this moyer those [ __ ] outfits and
[ __ ] that's they walk around like that
that's a lot of work though to be
walking around that's what the club
girls wear i know but like i said that's
a big dancer
dancing and [ __ ] anti-gravity [ __ ]
[ __ ] they got [ __ ] human blood flying
all right yeah we're dancing in the
human blood
rain yeah yeah
the human blood rain yeah i'm
down hernandez says matt tom is a genius
who needs a screenplay when you got
taught me [ __ ] right i'm just
inspiring this [ __ ] for free
for free i just gave that out oh y'all
could just like steal the ideas let's
see what they do how much that [ __ ]
comes out as a blockbuster [ __ ] movie
three years from now like damn where'd
this come from [ __ ] stole it from me
all right and i had to [ __ ] keep this
[ __ ] recorded all right and use this as
well see this is good because we're
recording it so if we have to sue some
[ __ ] later on that's right
we can prove that you came up with the
idea yeah you know what i mean
khan says we need to go fund me you
probably should i mean i don't know just
pick a comic book
it has lots of good ideas well comic
book is way cheaper you don't have to
like pay for like special effects you
can joke
you can just draw the [ __ ] yeah
like i said that's the nice thing about
being a writer yeah man you come up with
anything and you can just like write it
down it doesn't cost you anything words
are free google crowd source to comment
words are free and then uh
write up the comic and if it's [ __ ]
good we'll [ __ ] make a video game
based on it
yeah it'll be a space warfare game
all right yeah it'll be called sexual
tyrannosaurus yeah
yeah
or a [ __ ] hat
jenny can't stay on the motif okay
i'm just [ __ ] with you yeah i know i
know how you do i hate you i'm uh look
man we gotta get something to eat did
you wanna get something to eat you're
gonna work all night
well it wouldn't be the first time but
are you gonna make me some food yeah
what are you gonna come up on eleven
what are you gonna make hamburgers no
spam hamburgers okay nice man yeah
all right we're oh hamburger sounds good
yeah yeah you're a little pooky what's
she doing
what you doing resting
she's staring at my dictionary like it
yeah
like it's edible
yeah oh
all right holy [ __ ]
we've been going on this stream yeah
we've been going three hours i know i
don't remember how much we counted half
hours on the other one did we yeah holy
[ __ ] yeah sorry you guys yeah
you get into your drink and you forget
how long time to how long how much time
i'm having a good time it's friday night
we're not going anyplace no but we're
gonna get we're having a good time we're
talking to everybody
yeah i got to eat i'm starving
all right
so
oh bookie looks back here like what are
you guys talking about can you guys like
stop talking to the lights and start
talking to me
oh
all right we'll come and pay attention
pokey all right so we'll be back sunday
i hope maybe we'll talk about antlers
because i want to go see antlers
tomorrow so maybe we'll do a review of
that sunday you think yeah all right
okay cool we'll do that
all right so we're gonna go eat
thanks you guys for hanging out with us
on this friday night
we'll be back on sunday afternoon
yapping with you about whatever
and uh so i guess that'll be it right
you're done all right
all right good night you guys good night